was denn jetzt los chat, warum seid ihr denn schon am start?
jetzt hast du das twitch gegen ein stück zu hourbox kämpft
so auf gehts
wieder checke ich immer nicht genau was einem diese meldung sagen soll
ist es jetzt ein neuer sub oder ist es jetzt verlängerung wenn der sub abläuft ich habe keine
ahnung manchmal ist mir twitch zu feifett
muss man ja alles checken aber nice subscription
oh nice holt ja auch mal zeit
ich hab keine ahnung eigentlich müsste ich mittlerweile wissen wie twitch da funktioniert
aber wer weiß das schon
wir haben auch alle gedacht wir wissen ungefähr wie youtube funktioniert und dann kam raus wir
müssen alle community tab posts mit abstimmung machen was ist eigentlich aus meiner letzten
abstimmung rausgekommen ich hab mir das ganz großartig angeguckt ist jetzt ist es jetzt ist
es jetzt gif gif oder gif oder was ist es denn jetzt wie ich kann den das ist mal ein fake account
den ich mal angelegt habe lull da weiß doch da weiß doch im ernst dann immer das passwort
warum ist das da überhaupt noch drin
das weiß ich schon immer
warum kann man sich das nicht angucken ohne eingeloggt zu sein das ist doch fail
es haben einfach 12.000 leute abgestimmt lull
08 max danke für den sub exquisite 4 monate subscriptions
ich hab immer noch skype im hintergrund laufen am zweiten rechner kann ich amate installieren
also leute haben abgestimmt ich kann auf dem zweiten bildschirm nachgucken
abgestimmt 83 prozent gif 6 prozent gif und 11 prozent gif alles klar das heißt die wissen
ich kann auch verstehen warum sie es machen dass immer die comments ausgeschaltet sind
oh ne sind tatsächlich an ok ich hab nichts gesagt aber bei vielen dingen sind die comments
aus oder haben die ja genau ich weiß nicht kann es verstehen da gibt es halt ganz viele
nervige leute die willst du nicht moderieren müssen auf youtube gibt es so üblich die
üblichen verdächtigen aber das bei den amis weniger muss man sagen in den kokona news
in den kokona news wird fleißig drunter kommentiert und komische dinger von sich gegeben da interessiert
es anscheinend keinen
ich guck da nie rein das ist schon seit dem seit seit einem jahr ist es jetzt auf der
startseite von youtube ich glaube ich hab vielleicht insgesamt fünf videos angeklickt
innerhalb von einem jahr weil letztendlich ist es ja auch immer der gleiche kram was
willst du denn jeden tag da neues berichten alter genau bei dir die kokona leute lassen
es einfach was das achso zuschauer post we transform ja die ganzen zahlen was jucken
mich die ganzen zahlen die sind heute auch nicht so unterschiedlich wie gestern oder
vorgestern es reicht wenn man da einmal die woche reinguckt so ungefähr sieht aha ok
ist immer noch viel alles klar was wird es gar nicht jeden tag angucken was willst du
den tag anschauen 20 euro flip von ok excellent ok das müssen wir das hat ein bisschen was
von so einem ollen wie hießen die dinger die club handys die damals voll angesagt
fahren razor kenne kennen diese razor nicht razor oder ratze ratze die ratze war das motorola
war das motorola ratze phone ja motorola dieses zeug und ich weiß noch damals das
ist das ist ja überhaupt nicht mal angesagt mittlerweile kann durchaus sein dass sie
neues haben ich weiß nicht aber die alten die alten die gab es dann auch in gold genau
genau und ich kann mich noch dran erinnern genau die deutsche kabana ich kann mich noch
dran erinnern wo es dann irgendwelche medels gab auch bei uns die hatten dann irgendwie
so ein komisches golden razor deutsche und kabana edition und fanden sich extrem geil
damit das war so das war so der eines der ersten poser poser phones dabei war das gar
nicht so das war im vergleich zu den heutigen smartphone preisen war das der witz damals
hast du gedacht wenn du 350 euro für ein handy ausgegeben hast damals waren es ja noch
handys mit 350 euro für ein handy ausgegeben hat also das alter ist das krass teuer
und heute sagst du kein steiger gerät für 350 bezahlt quasi 1 da vor mehr und bezahlt
1350 was kostet doch ich weiß gar apple store was kostet das so gerade ich habe keine ahnung
was jetzt der kram gerade kostet die iphone kaufen sagt man ja was was kostet der kram
aktuell jetzt kaufen natürlich was sonst weiß wisst ihr was ich auch nicht verstehe
ist warum die leute das ist auch so ein punkt das kann ich noch nie nachvollziehen könnt
ihr euch noch an die schlangen vor den apple stores erinnern und ich habe mich damals immer
gefragt warum kämpfen leute vor apple stores wenn du dies einfach online bestellen kannst
hat da irgendwie einer nachvollziehbare erklärung für außer dass man quasi steve jobs und
apple holding wollte also was war der sinn vom apple store zu kämpfen wenn man sich
einfach online bestellen kann ok was kosten der kram hier iphone 12 pro das das bestimmt
das teuerste gerade oder weil ich mein 12 se gut se ist das was preisleistungsmäßig
eindeutig das beste ist es ist es absicht dass die apple seite so ah ne es lädt einfach
nur langsam dieser schritt ist kein sprung das das widerspricht sich schon mal in in
sich das ist wie dass dieser schritt ist jetzt ein sprung ist ungefähr wie wenn ich jetzt
sage diese treppe ist jetzt ein fahrstuhl das ergibt einfach keinen sinn kostet shop
ach leute ey lass mich doch einfach kaufen müssen wir erstmal anpreisen ok es hört
gar nicht mehr auf alter ich will so einfach nur kaufen lass mich kaufen ah ok kost natürlich
das fetteste alles klar 512 was äh macht es nen unterschied ja ey wenn schon so natürlich
die gold 512 easy nein natürlich nicht alter 1599 1600 euro ok das macht ja auch keiner
irgendwie bei verstand ist ne also 512 g ist komplett bescheuert und selbst 128 g ist eigentlich
noch zu viel und wisst ihr was der große witz ist dass der kram überhaupt so viel kostet
ich meine die wollen ernsthaft guck mal 120 euro für 128 g dafür kriegst du ja schon
ein halbes halbes terabyte terabyte nvme ssd passt weiß jetzt gerade aus dem kopf nicht
aber auf jeden fall mehr also die die verdienen so extrem heftig an dem speicher upgrade das
ist der wahnsinn ey die verdienen sich so heftig da ein ab von guck mal die sind auch
nicht doof guck mal hier erhöht sich um 120 euro und hier erhöht sich um 230 euro also
die die sagen dass du spaßt sogar noch ein bisschen was wenn du 512 nimmst oh exzellent
exzellent brauch ich kein match keine sau braucht es so ok was kosten aktuelles iphone
se das ist finde ich immer noch das sinnvollste iphone was man sich kaufen kann weiß schwarz
warum gibt es es nicht mehr in ganz normal silber oder gab sie in oder space gray oder
wie es immer hieß ich mein das ist schon früher richtung top smartphone gegangen 479 ja aber
das geht das geht das geht noch irgendwie also ich würde mir wenn ich mir ein iphone
kaufen würde dann würde ich mir das kaufen ganz im ernst was kosten die aktuellen ipads
ich war nämlich auch überlegen ob ich wieder ob ich mir ob ich mir ok geht noch ob ich
mir einen ipad holen soll weil wenn man feier tablet echt auf den sack geht aber dann fällt
mir wieder auf also wisst ihr ich gucke ja auf so einen billigen amazon feier tablet
abends so ein bisschen twitch und youtube so und dann überlege ich mir vielleicht sollte
ich mir auch mal ein ipad holen weil android tablets sacken zum größten teil habe ich
schon oft genug ausprobiert so fürs tägliche benutzen und ich verwerf das dann immer wieder
weil mir dann einfällt dass ich auf dem ipad keinerlei möglichkeiten habe werbeblocker
richtig zu benutzen also sprich wenn du wenn du youtube twitch irgendwas gucken willst
kannst du das unter android wunderbar machen da gibt es die passenden apps mit werbeblocker
unter ipad nicht dementsprechend ist eigentlich das ipad so um abends im bett stream zu gucken
kacke da war ich da war ich lieber fünf sekunden länger guckst auf einen billigen feier hd
exzellent das bringt dir aber nix wenns youblog für ios gibt weil das höchstens im safari
greift und nicht in youtube app oder twitch app das ist das problem du hast also du hast
realistisch betrachtet keine chance youtube ohne ads zu gucken auf dem iphone ne zu viel
zu fett so ein convertible laptop höchstens höchstens höchstens in surface was kosten
die aktuell in sind echt geteurer normalerweise würde ich eigentlich mein ipad nicht flaschen
man kann es bestimmt man kann es weiß gar nicht ob man die routen kann kann man aktuelle
ipads routen geht das noch ne also daran sieht man das also man ist halt wie das halt so
der vorteil und gleichzeitig der nachteil bei der ganzen geschichte du bist halt hier
auf githai und verderben apple ausgeliefert bei android kannst du noch viel einstellen
auch ohne zu routen kannst du bei android total viel zeug drehen hast du schon mal tausend
zuschauermarke geknackt ich glaube das höchste was ich hatte war mal 950 oder haben wir uns
witzigerweise glaube ich den apple livestream angeguckt ja also deswegen deswegen will
ich mir kein ipad ich würde mir am liebsten ein ipad kaufen für abends im bett streams
gucken ja aber dadurch dass ich keine werbe blocker sind von verwenden kann es sagt und
wisst ihr das nervt mich ich schon ich gucke ja ganz gern ein bisschen youtube videos zum
einschlafen im bett so ich gucke dann ich gucke mir dann irgendwie was weiß ich irgendwie
was weiß ich der entfernteste ort im universum bla bla bla irgendwelche space doku geschichten
oder irgendwas an so das problem ist das kannst du dir auf dem iphone nicht angucken weil
auf dem iphone alle acht minuten oder so mal werbung kommt und das geht halt auf das geht
dir halt auf den sack blickst du im bett guckst du dir das an und pensst dann und pensst
dann und auf einmal kommt dann irgendwie der strato scooter oder sowas wobei gibts den
überhaupt noch den strato scooter kennt ihr noch den strato oder der scooter für strato
strato strato richtig fail alter es hat mir nur gerade einmal auf den letzten strato angeguckt
haben also für das youtube premium 150 aus indien wie geht denn das kann man das machen
das wäre tatsächlich eine gute idee ja ich sehe es nicht ein youtube premium zu bezahlen
aber 150 150 und wie bezahlt man dann dort paypal oder oder der bei twitch nicht aber
twitch ist mit werbung nicht schlimm twitch hält sich echt zurück zumindest bei mir
auf mobile mit werbung da kommt ab und zu mal eine werbung aber es ist nicht so wild
wie macht man das wie bezahlt man denn indische indisches youtube premium level battlefield
3 video von levelcap gesehen ist es ist das wenn es was er zeigt oder oder nicht ok das
gucken wir uns gleich mal an was auf my deals ok gucken wir mal also premium also ich also
für 150 im monat würde ich mich dazu hin reißen lassen extra app für twitch ja nur
mit dem unterschied dass die app übel sagt die habe ich auch schon mal ausprobiert also
auf auf android auf android auf auf auf ios gibt sie gar nicht oder gibt sie auch auf
ios manchmal ist der chat manchmal chat ist echt thema verfehlt aber die sagt die habe
ich auf android auch schon ausprobiert die ist echt beispielsweise wenn du die clips
angucken willst hast du nun endlich lange liste und es hört nie auf und sowas leute es geht
nicht um android und android habe ich kein problem es geht um ios ich glaube chat braucht
jetzt eine stunde lang asmr maus sounds dass sie wieder zur besinnung kommen vpn zum pie
hole nein das bringt auch nix pie hole block keine ads auf twitch und youtube mehr zuverlässig
youtube geht noch aber twitch geht beispielsweise gar nicht mehr weil die content und ads vom
gleichen server ausliefern
es geht um ios nicht um android proxy server bringt auch nix weil proxy server bringt aus
dem grund nichts weil die youtube app auf android auf ios natürlich big prank gemacht
ist und die zertifikate kontrolliert das heißt du kannst nicht so einfach dich connecten
über den proxy server zu youtube oder https tja dann zumindest doch das kannst du machen
aber der proxy kann nicht reingucken der kann es einfach nur weiter leiten so also zeigt
mal her wie youtube premium kauf über indien ok ok wie geht das dort kostet das solo aber
nur 929 rupiah umrecht 149 excellent das family aber ok indische vpn gut es ist kein problem
indisches vpn is easy as fuck aber muss man muss eine kreditkarte verwenden kann man nicht
paypal oder so nehmen ok ne man muss man muss das wohl mit man muss das wohl mit kreditkarte
machen ok gut kein problem argentinien jetzt wird es alle länder aus wo es noch billiger
ist auch keine ahnung ok also im prinzip im prinzip geht man geht man über den vpn auf
youtube komm premium und dann ok ja das könnte ich tatsächlich machen easy ich mein ich mein
so 1149 oder so im monat für keine werbung ist in ordnung was kosten was kostet das
eigentlich gerade hier in deutschland was was ernsthaft sind die doch ganz dicht 11
euro 99 hat es sich mal fünf euro gekostet oder so
ja mich juckt music streaming nicht krass 11 euro 99 alter dafür kriegst du ja schon
amazon prime und und gedönst alles umsonst weiß gar nicht was amazon prime im monat kostet
aktuelle de
anders gerade für den sound das habe ich jetzt verwert alles in der musik
ach nee das war das war in der musik dieses bling geil dass irgendeine musik aufgenommen
hat sein sein sein discord noch an oder so ja wo steht jetzt was es kostet 799 im monat
so und music ultimate kostet was oder unlimited also du kriegst fast amazon prime music unlimited
zusammen für das was du youtube kriegst also ganz ehrlich 1199 für youtube adfrei ist
der witz wisst ihr was cool war als twitch noch ad adfrei war mit mit prime ja man könnte
man könnte vom iphone rdp oder so auf ne windows kiste und dort im browser aber das ist von
der bedienung her doch auch scheiße ja wie viel kostet turbo gute frage 899 ist es ehrlich
gesagt auch zu viel ist ehrlich gesagt auch zu viel also überlegt
euch mal ihr bezahlt dann 20 euro 20 euro im monat würdet ihr bezahlen für youtube und
twitch werbefreie das sehe ich nicht ein aber so youtube youtube premium über indien klingt
eigentlich ganz sinnvoll mach mal ausrufe zeichen 1 das habe ich schon ein paar mal
erklärt so ok was gucken wir uns jetzt mal an also das von level cap können wir uns
ja mal angucken genau bin ich mal gespannt aber was zu wenn es sagt was ja leider letzten
tage ziemlich dead ist was aber auch an rumgejeete und merkwürdigen sachen liegt da übertreibt
man nicht
das ist egal ob das jetzt ein ad blocker auf linux basis oder auf windows basis ist die
werden beide twitch beispielsweise nicht richtig blocken können das ist level cap na gut welche
plattform ist schon mal klar entweder pc oder eventuell noch xbox aber nur weil es
beckworts kompatible beckwort kompatibilität wie auch immer ihr wisst was ich meine ja
das beste ist ja aber sich über den keyshop zu kaufen der kostet 350 oder so m16kw m16
hc og wer macht denn sowas ja und die lichter und die lichter im single player waren alle
von hand positioniert das war nix dynamisches auf der konsole ich weiß gar nicht wie es
auf dem pc war ja ja klar die abscalen das halt die abscalen
das halt wie gesagt du musst du musst da so ein pc spielen also das stimmt battlefield
3 sieht echt gut aus also auch 2020 noch 2021 noch also zehn jahre schon alt und läuft
halt auch wirklich auf jedem krab
echt echt das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen
es gibt halt fünf server wo leute drauf sind auf die anderen geht doch keiner ja das gameplay
ist wirklich nicht so geil
ich spiele eh nicht quick match ich spiele in battlefield quick match du suchst den gamemode
aus in das spiel wenn es geht es auf einen der drei server die spieler hat und joins
und gut ist
deswegen fühlt sich das auch so komisch an also der unterschied zwischen wenn es und
und vanilla ist da schon zu spüren allerdings fühlt sich wenn es in manch anderen bereichen
deswegen irgendwie ungewohnt und komisch an also
es gibt einen quick play aber es benutzt keiner
also es gibt so viele runden wo du irgendwelche 65 und drei heli dudes am start hast weil
die gegner sich auf die reihe kriegen und du halt alleine nur begrenzt was machen kannst
es sei denn du geierst die ganze runde mit iklaricht in himmel
mir fällt jetzt erst mal wieder so auf wie dunkel krent bazaar aussieht ich kenne ja
nur noch die venice variante wo die sonne scheint
man muss man muss die anti suppression park nehmen sonst kann man das nicht spielen das
game schießt er heute auch noch mal schießt er heute auch noch mal und trifft er schon
was mein aktuell schießt er noch nicht einmal alter
ich sage jetzt noch nicht mal dass du sowas hitten musst das ist in battlefield 3 gar
nicht so einfach aber da hätte ich den clip nicht reingenommen ich mein hallo 30 sekunden
durch scope gucken zweimal in die richtung ballen und ertreffen und sterben das ist
doch kein clip den ich ins video mache
aber jetzt erzähl dir was zu venice das muss ich mal kurz zurückspulen
ja ok da hat das video
das video heute morgen hoch nie wann hat es hochgeladen
leute wann kam das video sieht man das irgendwie richtig
muss man kurz in venice reingucken ob jetzt leute am start sind wenn level cap was hoch
geladen hat sind
was passiert jetzt
das ist bazaar warte mal warte mal ich muss mal kurz custom map custom map muss man kurz
checken custom map wir gucken wir gucken nur ganz kurz wir gucken nur ganz kurz custom
map game laden please
sieht das kacke aus aber schon mal gute gute basis
ok ok es sieht halt aus wie die map ist ohne miss die map ist nicht schlecht das ist das
ist ziemlich gut gemacht halt es fehlen alle es fehlen komplett die props auf der map
das ist echt ganz gut gemacht es fehlt halt komplett jeglicher inhalt auf der map aber
ansonsten ist es nicht schlecht es fehlt halt alles auf der map keine props und nichts
ja also ist ok das ist das ist durchaus in ordnung das ist durchaus in ordnung
guck mal da wir zwar mit der as wall rum genubt ist durchaus in ordnung
kacke wade kacke wade kacke wade
ok der erste tut schon ganz schön lang da drin mit 38 39 hast du die kompanie schon
mal gespielt ja das stimmt das ist die wille aus der story ja klar stimmt das ist die wille
aus der story da wo man da wo da wo der russe am start ist der russe mit dem swimming pool
wo ist der swimming pool aber aber aber ist ist sie in der city im single player auch
so schlecht beleuchtet und so schlecht ausgestattet aus mit mit items und so oh hier kann man
captchern auch noch aber es ist cool dass die wille ich finde das ist eine gute sache
oh na eimt weg na eimt lull b what the fuck ja ist klar natürlich mit der mit der pistol
open the egg die mehr part assets vom siebertauer aber ladebildschirm aber wir nehmen jetzt mal
andere waffe aber ladebildschirm ist hier auch op close quarter close quarters ding
oder oder oder excellent ja bestimmt schon eine wochen immer wochen immer gespielt weil
wenn es leer war ja klar da haben sie aber kein höhere t-grade ja eigentlich wollte
ich jetzt gar keine bänne viel drei spiel aber ich finde es cool dass sie die wille
drin haben echt nice sowas nehmen jetzt mal das aus quad cover cover ist eigentlich das
wichtigste exquisite guck mal da da stellts da vor uns lull b geiler stellzer man keck
keck weight but why what the fuck ich hör da über mir irgendwas rennen wo ist der pool
aus dem single player kann man hier raus au ne fuck jetzt kommt man nicht mehr rein wait
wait wait wait ah von der side alter ok einmal dankeschön für den prall einmal spawn ich
glaube dann ist gut war die map im single player sah die auch so kacke beleuchtet aus
war das nicht bei nacht war die single player mission nicht bei nacht und nicht bei was
wollte ich sagen nicht genau die single player mission war bei nacht und und und irgendwie
war die auch besser ok es hier muss man single play irgendwas machen genau what the fuck ok
die map ist nicht für multiplayer gedacht wünsch mal behaupten ach genau das ist ich
erinnere mich wieder dran das ist dieser komische treten dieser diese jaja das ist single player
hier genau genau die map ist halt mal absolut nicht für multiplayer gedacht alles klar alles
klar ja mag noch one shot easy 100 prozent ja ok nice gucken wir mal weiter
filter in most importantly du brauchst einmal ich brauchst du origin offen offen wenn du
dich connect ist dann nicht mehr offer some great features high tech rate servers no blue
filter in most importantly no suppression plus there's other features like 100 player servers
custom modes and more on top of that there are some du kannst das glaube sogar diens
ne wobei keine ahnung habe ich nicht ausprobiert du musst auf jeden fall nicht starten und
manchmal teilt das out das game die die out origin autodifizierung dann musst du es noch
mal noch mal starten also kann es nicht so praktikabel da bin ich übrigens mal gespannt
drauf das soll ergeblich im ersten quartal erscheinen dieser reality mod
es gibt einige große mods auf dem Weg wie ein project reality mod aka squad total conversion
für die hier und jetzt denke ich venice unleashed ist wahrscheinlich der beste Weg zurück
zu battlefield 3 wenn du ein veteran player bist ich würde sagen die bessere tickrate und
erhöhte playercounts sehen mehr aus wie gimmicks als wertvolle feature battlefield 3 wurde
auf der technologie derzeit gebaut und es beyond that just nicht so gut zu machen
but the servers are running pretty standard rule sets and i will say the quality of the
servers are solid even compared to the more popular third party server providers out there
many of the standard servers that you would find problem ist problem ist halt nur das grad
irgendwie keine honest would be running metro 24 7 or have weird hardcore rules or tons
of instant vehicles any of the standard servers that you would find outside of venice unleashed
would be running metro 24 7 or have weird hardcore rules tons of instant vehicles spawned
but despite being a mod client venice unleashed servers typically run with vanilla rules with
stuff like suppression turned off as for getting venice unleashed up and running the process
is pretty straightforward just download their client installer from their website sign
in with your origin id and you'll be good to go the only catch is that the population
of players using venice unleashed is a lot lower leider leider es die müssten also würde
da jetzt ohne mist würde level cap wie ist der andere typ noch mal level cap und wiesen
der andere dude jack frax genau wenn die mal wenn die mal da ordentlich was zu machen würden
dann wäre das auch voll in the matchmaking sogar sogar als ich dazu was gemacht habe
hatte schon geführt dass 23 server voll waren oder voller waren slower so da peak hours
you might struggle to actually find populated servers in all regions that said with big
mods on the way i expect venice unleashed will only get more popular over time ja hoffe
ich hoffe ich aktuell ist es eher umgedreht i'm diving into battlefield 3 i do have some
advice for weapon load ads and classes you can use to get started the assault class aka
the medic is probably the easiest and best starting class you get assault rifles which
are some of the best weapons of the game and the role of the medic is extremely cool dass
du medic spielen kannst mit engineer waffen mit med bags and revive them with a frankie on pc gibt
ja nicht mehr der macht irgendwie seit drei jahren recon players have a lot more nuance to their
roles and support is basically a bullet factory for your teammates and it has some insane weapons
if you decide to start with the assault class the m416 the m16 a3 and the ak 971 are probably the best
weapons for the class now it is practically the m16 a3 at this point i don't think you can go
wrong with it it works close quarters long range and everywhere in between it's also the gun you
start with barrel gives you better ads accuracy okay ne ne er macht battlefield 3 geil im jahr
2021 so easy many 24 7 metro inflated xp servers that will likely get you entire class unlocks in
an evening when it comes to hyper specific class mechanics they are a bit beyond this video scope
but my advice is to use your classes gadgets as much as possible if you have an ammo crate make
sure to place it down when you're around teammates to resupply their ammo this support is a class
guide stops that does require decent map knowledge and okay das muss man ja kommen map geil
battlefield 3 geil in 2021 glaube ich ein bisschen zu viel des gunn
ja ich mache ja noch nicht so lange wieder auf youtube was so viel gibt es da gar nicht
zu gucken so ich muss mal kurz musik anschmeißen habe ich meine musik
ok ja wenn wir jetzt gerade bei battlefield sind kommen wir kucken uns wir kucken uns
wir kucken uns noch eine runde mit 3 an wenn wir schon bei battlefield waren er wieder den
haben wir letztens gehostet und wir haben gelernt als ich ihn gehostet habe er kann sogar deutsch
oder ist ist sogar in deutsch ich weiß nicht genau zumindest spricht er ziemlich gut deutsch
das ist übrigens absichtlich ein bisschen leiser weil der kommentator typ immer das
gleiche erzählt alter die werden aber wieder weggesprayt aber da ist er da ist er in seinem
element alter da ist er in seinem element metro metro conquest in your face das kann er das
das macht dazu macht er zum großen teil im stream aber die hat er heftig was ist das für
eine waffe die er da hat mg 36 das hat kaum einer gespielt das war richtig poggers in bad
company 2 ist mg 36 alter die geschehen da merkt aber die vanilla geschichte dass die dass die
hits verzögert sind das ist er den ich gehostet habe ja der macht der spiel wirklich leise
leise battlefield streams am start wenn man das noch gucken will wirst du die bad company 3
holen es gibt bett company 3 ist doch noch nicht mal am horizont was ist das für ein ding was
ist das für eine waffe da stand doch vorhin was anderes
da stand vorher ms ach das die granate ich habe mich verguckt alter ich kacke
2 mal in the ask schudet
weg rpg rpg und inf cool ist ja ich bin da zu faul bei sowas für hetzschutz zu
aber davon abgesehen wahrscheinlich würde ich nicht treffen aber ich bin ich bin da eigentlich
zu faul weil die sache ist die in battlefield in battlefield ist der headshot modifier jetzt
nicht so also mal hier ist klar hier musste die weg weg springen ja aber bei dem nächsten
typ der in die andere richtung guckt der hier jetzt kommt oder habe ich das schon der da da
hätte ich überhaupt kein headshot gemacht bei dem typ bei dem hättest du in der gleichen zeit
einfach zwei body shots verpassen können wäre schneller gewesen in battlefield 3 oder
da werden sie weggesprägt nice aber der hat schon die esch gut guck mal an ich hab gar nicht
überlebt aktiviert der spielt der spielt irgendwie immer mit mit deaktiviertem windows ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht warum ich meine du kannst ja heute eine windows lizenz holen für
fünf dollar oder so
da hat aber ganz schön viel bass im sound
der sebaro der hat massig kieser und nicht nur und nicht nur kieser sebaro hat nicht
nur kies nicht nur windows kies
ok da ist cool wenn das trifft ja wir treffen wissen wir das der ist nice allerdings gehen
mir so leute immer auf den sack die bringen nämlich überhaupt null für die jeweilige
runde der typ der hat vielleicht ja das waren die einzigen zwei kills vielleicht ihre die
ganze runde gemacht hat dafür waren das nice kills across the map kills aber gebracht hat
nix
sag mal sag mal was ist denn da los ist es sniper duel server oder was die sitzen im
spawn und die sitzen im spawn das ist doch keine normale runde die haben sich einfach
auf den server gehockt und machen jetzt gegenseitig nice sniper duel
schwachsinn alter
außerdem warum macht er keine 360 scopes ja
doch das ist eine normale runde das ist aber allein schon hier in der ecke ich meine da
siehst du schon dass der im prinzip zu der runde nix großartig beiträgt auf beiden seiten
allerdings außer darum zu sitzen und zu snipen
du erkennst sofort du erkennst echt sofort dass es nicht wenn es ist für plau wie das
ist das ist das ist was ist für eine auflösung
das sieht ein bisschen gestretched aus das ist gestretched das ist keine 800 mal 600
800 mal 600 gestretched oder irgendwie sowas
und kleines vorfahre
ja in den smoke gesprayt
in den smoke gesprayt sehr nice also ich meine es ist krass auf killfeed richtig krass
aber ob es ein richtiges top play weiß ich nicht es ist halt ultra killfeed ja
alter die werden weggesprayt aber unterm strich hat es keinem team was gebracht außer ihm
einen hohen killcounter weil die alle wieder beliebt wurden
aber trotzdem ist natürlich nice so ein killfeed am start
oh ich dachte es gibt jetzt irgendwie ein fünfer collateral
leute ohne mist also jetzt mal ernsthaft als ihr das gerade gesehen habt habt ihr nicht
auch gedacht fünfer fünfer collateral kommt
also ich dachte die laufen jetzt alle hintereinander und dann macht ihr ein vierer fünfer collateral
in your face aber nee gibt's nicht
aber dass er die alle headshot hat ist schon nicht schlecht
oh nice wie rennen flanken wollte den kopf weggeballert hat
nice cool
das ist also das ist gar nicht mal so ohne hier
aber warum ist der letzte dude jetzt nicht gestorben
ah doch ist ist
nee ist nicht der letzte dude ist nicht gestorben oder
ja ok da weiß man das ist battlefield logik da weiß man jetzt nicht ob es ein headshot
war oder nicht das ist schwierig zu sagen in battlefield 3 teilweise
warum schießt er gegen die box
er ist schon wieder am start
nice erstmal schön eingesmoked
er spielt ja nur 90 prozent metro
der macht das übrigens immer so ich hab mir den streamer mal angeguckt also ist wirklich
cool zu gucken das maugt sich immer ein ab und dann macht er dann macht er keine ik silencer
spreche alles weg oder sowas
eigentlich ziemlich big brain tactics für metro 64
ok es ist g3 mit silencer
leider hat die g3 ein bisschen zu wenig ammo für sowas
leider hat die
g3 silencer ist ehrlich gesagt nicht so meins
aber ich spiele die auch als singel schuss vielleicht soll ich dir auch mal ein bisschen
mehr auto spielen
ok ok jetzt wissen wir was kommt
der flank of doom hinten rum durch die spawnzone und dann werden die hier gleich alle richtig
ja wie drückt man das korrekt aus was passiert mit den gegnern jetzt gleich
ich würd sagen sowas wie weggefickt halt
weg gachi buster
hat er ihn nicht gesehen alter und jetzt geht die munition aus nein
er spielte
METRO ist ein guter Streak auf BRAVO Objective.
Wenn man so viele Töne bekommt, wird METRO eines der Maps, an dem wir vielleicht 5 oder 6 Klips sehen.
Das Top-Play-Episode geht zurück in die Popularität, die wir zuerst gesehen haben, als das Spiel entstanden wurde.
Es ist nur ein Maps, an dem man einen Killstreak bekommen kann, wenn man in den Maps loggt.
Deshalb sehen wir so viel davon.
Ein Fan-Favorit, der sicherlich in den nächsten Battlefield-Spiel zurückkehren wird.
Das denke ich übrigens auch, das denke ich übrigens auch.
Nachdem die ja schon gezeigt haben, dass DICE jetzt nicht mal so die Wahnsinns-Kreativität hat wie früher,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die ganz viele der Best-of-Maps wieder in Battlefield 6 bringen.
Ich mag METRO ehrlich gesagt auch nicht, ganz im Ernst.
METRO ist nice, METRO kannst du mal eine Runde spielen, aber dann dauert ja auch eine halbe Stunde oder so oder länger,
je nachdem was das Ticket-Counts ist und Conquest.
Aber dann ist es auch gut, dann will ich für den ganzen Abend kein METRO mehr spielen.
Selbst Rush ist ätzend.
Juhuuu!
Brrrrrrrrrt!
Clickmaps!
Thronax, Dankeschön, Subscription!
Massive Sub!
Was ist diese Musik da im Hintergrund eigentlich?
Intense music
Aha
Oh
Schneiber, nicht Schneiber, äh, äh, Shotgun
Bäm, bäm, bäm
Jawoll
Alles weg mit dem Shotgun, nächstes bitte, bäm
Sag mal Gegner seid ihr komplett verwirrt? Ja anscheinend
Oh nice nice
Nice nice
Ja für sowas ist die Shotgun nice
Oh, das da rauszuhippen gegen den Sniper war grad echt mutig
Ich, zum Glück treffen die das nicht
Ich fand eigentlich fast alle Maps in Battlefield 3 spielbar, Metro war halt ätzend mit der Zeit und ich muss euch halt sagen ich war auch kein Caspian Border Fan
Da ist mir zu wenig passiert, Infanterie-Action
Okay, Epicenter Rush ist wirklich Spains Champ, ja das stimmt
Magnum-Stellz
Winner activate Windows
Warum rennen die Gegner voll in die Granate rein? Was ist, was, was ist mit den Gegnern hier grad los?
Ich mein er wirft jetzt die Nate, so, Nate und die Gegner denken sich ach ja, lass uns mal, lass uns mal voll in die Nate rein rennen, jawoll, so ist das gut
Was auch immer, okay das ist aber ein nicer Streak, nicer Streak mit der Magnum
Silvertank, neun Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub
And the Tingos
Was macht eigentlich Big Shack? Gibt es von ihm irgendwas neues?
Big Muffz
Oh erstmal, warum ist er nebenbei? Am Chips futtern?
Oder ist das jetzt, oder ist das irgendwie so ein Taunt, so ein Taunt gegen die Gegner, so nach dem Motto, ich mach euch easy mit einer Hand und Chips futtern, futtern, kaputt
Ah, ein Kokomodate am Start, weggesnackt, ja, weggesnackt
Nice, exquisite, okay was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an? Erst mal ein bisschen Musik anmachen
Ah, das geht immer mal, das geht immer, das geht immer, also wenn es Video 2.13 geht, weiß man ja schon, der legt jetzt einmal Hand auf und du schloss es auf
Da macht er irgendwie einen von seinen Special Schlüsseln rein, wackelt dreimal und es ist offen
Was frühstückst du eigentlich immer? Weißes Brötchen? Ganz 0-15?
Was ist Home Depot? Ist Home Depot irgendwie so ein Baumarkt bei den Amis? So was wie Obi?
Also sprich, wenn man ordentliches Werkzeug haben will geht man nicht zu Home Depot
Oh, ein Leco, exquisite Subscription
Okay, das Teil hat er immer irgendwie am Start, ich meine der hat es schon drauf, ne? Der wackelt als dreimal und es ist offen
Oh, ja ne, easy, drehen offen, aha, alles klar
Ich hab zwar keine Ahnung was er erzählt, aber es sieht easy aus, ist wahrscheinlich nicht easy
Also für seine Verhältnisse hat er schon recht lange gebraucht
Nice
Okay, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Okay, so einen hab ich noch, ich hab noch einen 3DS, wollt ihr mal gucken wie man den flashen kann, das hab ich sogar vor, mal im Stream zu machen
Und wir gucken uns jetzt das mit dem 3DS an
Ach, das LL ist die chinesische Variante
Also wenn Nintendo sagt es war accidental, also unabsichtlich, dann glaub ich Nintendo nix mehr, Nintendo erzählt in den letzten Jahren so viel Schwachsinn
Also Nintendo ist mittlerweile kein Deut besser als irgendwelche anderen, sei es jetzt EA oder Activision oder sonst was
Zumal das Problem ist, dass es aktuell mal wieder keine Spiele auf der Switch gibt, ne?
Was ist mit der PS Vita geworden? Ja nix, in Japan war das Ding ja mäßig beliebt, in restlichen Teilen der Welt gar nicht und Sony juckt es halt nicht
Ja ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich finde einen DS ist mir, ich halte so einen DS auch viel lieber in der Hand als eine Switch
Weiß nicht, wie soll ich da gehen, aber ich finde die Switch immer noch nicht, du kannst da mit mobil spielen, aber angenehm finde ich das nicht
Ich würde lieber einen DS zuklappen und den Rucksack schmeißen, als einen Switch in den Rucksack schmeißen
Ja ounces, da haben wir richtig schöne wieder Freedom Units am Start
Der DS hat einen Browser? Die Switch hat es bis heute nicht geschafft
Ich weiß, dass die Switch absichtlich keinen hat, aber das ist affisch für ein Mobile, nennen wir es mal Tablet ohne Browser
Ich meine es gibt noch nicht mal, gibt es mittlerweile YouTube und Netflix und Twitch für Switch?
Ich hätte nämlich eigentlich vermutet, dadurch dass das mehr oder weniger die gleiche Basis ist wie das Nvidia Shield, hätte ich eigentlich gedacht, dass ganz viele Android Apps da sich easy portieren lassen
Aber Tja, Nintendo weiß nicht
Ok, das Problem ist mittlerweile, dass YouTube das Video für Hacking flaggen kann und sein Channel löscht
Ich habe gesagt latscht, latscht, latscht hier
Der Seitentitel ist ja schon mal geil
3ds.dex.guide klingt als das Vertrauenserwecken erstmal
Ok Leute, wir machen das im Stream, ich habe ja noch einen quasi nagelneuen 3ds
Ja
Oh, toll
Sag euch, weil ich es gerade sehe, Codename Rosalina, Rosalina ist das beste Nintendo Grill
Da kann Peach und Winster noch so alles einpacken Leute, ich sage Rosalina, beste
Craigasm
Ja, klingt so
Warum gibt es eigentlich noch so Dinge wie Region Lock im Jahr 2000? Wann kam das raus? 2017? 16?
Mein Region Lock, das ist so ein antikes Ding aus Zeiten wo es noch PAL und NTFS und so ein Geschiss gab
Stonks, ja noch nicht mal die verkaufen ja mehr
Na gut, bei Nintendo weißt ihr eh nicht so genau was los ist mit denen
Ja, bei Nintendo weißt ihr eh nicht, ich meine guckt euch mal den Animal Crossing Multiplayer an
Also viel schlechter kann es ja nicht mehr kommen
Habe ich NTFS gesagt? Ich meine PAL und NTSC, habe ich NTFS gesagt echt? Ja ja NTSC
Okay
Na gut, den eShop braucht man ja genau genommen nicht mehr
Was ist am Animal Crossing Multiplayer schlecht? Du hast z.B. das Problem dass du Fortschritt verlierst wenn die Session
Crashed, was totaler Fail ist, dass man nichts zusammen machen kann und was hat das Spiel irgendwie hängt beim
Leaven und Join und dass derjenige der Join kein Progress machen kann, da musst du dir mal ein paar Listen angucken, das ist mega für'n Arsch
Das kommt dir vor wie ein Multiplayer Spiel von 2001
Ich finde es nicht gut Sachen++ dahinter zu nennen, das erweckt Assoziationen mit C++, was gleichbedeutend ist mit großer Crap-Programmiersprache
Ja, so muss das sein
Es gab auf dem, für den normalen DS gab es damals auch schon SNES Emulator, der hat nicht richtig funktioniert
Kann mich noch dran erinnern, weiß nicht ob jemand von euch einen originalen DS hatte, ich habe mir damals so eine Flashkarte gekauft
und da konntest du dann auch Custom Software drauf machen z.B. den SNES Emulator und das war halt Crap
Ja Matt, das ist genauso wie ESP und Microcontroller-Programmier, da gibt es keine Alternative, das macht C++ aber nicht besser
Okay, wundert mich nicht, Nintendo hat es ja auch verkackt mit der Mario Collection
Okay, das haben die aber extra kompiliert dafür, würde mich interessieren ob das Ding ein N460 Emulator hat, der ordentlich funktioniert, könnte ein bisschen eng werden
Das ist ein wirklich beeindruckender Port und es ist toll, ihn auf dem Nintendo 3DS zu sehen
Boah, das ist ja schon, da reicht der normale Subscriber nicht mehr aus
Das ist ja schon, Exzellent
Moment, but why?
Wie um alles in der Welt willst du ordentlich Diablo spielen auf dem 3DS?
Senpi, zwei Monate Dankeschön für den Zapp
Da kannst du nicht mal gescheit Items aufnehmen
Natürlich, natürlich, so mache ich das auch, also ich würde auf meinem geflashten 3DS selbstverständlich nur Originalspiele spielen, die ich vorher gedumpt habe auf einer SD-Karte
Und das solltet ihr auch nur machen, alles andere wäre ja Monka Toss und sowas wollen wir ja nicht gut heißen, Sicherheitskopien muss man machen
Warum C-Doppelpunkt? Warum ist man so ein großer Windows-Fan, damit man in der Custom-DS-Firmware den SD-Karten Mountpunkt C-Doppelpunkt nennt?
Oh, was ist da passiert?
Natürlich, natürlich darf man das nur machen, wenn man das Original-Cartridge hat
Er hat CIA mit Hilfe von FBI installiert, Big Brain
Und obwohl Nintendo die Produktion des 3DS-Hardware letztes Jahr aufhörte, geht die Homebrew-Szene nicht weiter
Und in vielen Fällen ist es der beste und interessanteste, der da ist
Wenn du deine 2DS oder 3DS noch nicht moddiert hast, solltest du es wirklich nachdenken
Das ist die neue Nintendo 3DS-LL, die wir moddiert haben für die Homebrew-Szene
Aber das ist nicht alles, wir geben die gleiche neue Nintendo 3DS-LL, die wir in diesem Video gesehen haben, weg
Exquisite
Twitter? Okay, was schauen wir uns jetzt an?
Ja, es gibt DS-Android-Emulatoren, also nein umgedreht, auf Android-DS-Emulatoren
Twitter
So sieht die Zukunft aus, okay GameStar
Dann zeigen wir uns mal GameStar, was sind die besten Games 2001, als müssten die das schon genau
Schön, schön, schön, schön verbackt vor allem, Moment, schön verbackt
War das Cyberpunk? Nee, das war gar kein Cyberpunk, sah auf den ersten Blick so aus
Ach komm
Alter Watch Dogs, das ist so ein Game
Ich habe den, ich habe, Watch Dogs habe ich schon den ersten Teil gespielt und auch nicht komplett fertig
Aber Watch Dogs ist so eine Serie geworden, wo ich immer nicht verstanden habe, was sie jetzt eigentlich wollen
Wollen sie jetzt möglichst coolen Hacker-Hipster-Shit machen oder wollen sie irgendwie serious was erzählen mit Bezug zu
Ich verstehe nicht, was Watch Dogs will von mir
Außerdem haben mich die Trailer null angesprochen von Watch Dogs 2, also der Watch Dogs 2 Trailer war einfach nur
Wir machen Ultra auf Hipster und möchte gern Hacker, was mit der Realität nichts zu tun hat
Und Watch Dogs 3 war auch so auf möchte gern Hacker gemacht, also
Was ist eigentlich aus Unity geworden, welches Unity
Das Assassin's Creed, das interessiert auch keinen mehr, es gibt täglich, es gibt jährlich ein neues Assassin's Creed
Unity ist vor 5 Jahren oder so rausgekommen
Ey ja, übertreibt es halt mal mit Spiele-Lautstärke zu Sprecher-Lautstärke
Oh, das war es für mich
Neko, 17 Monate, danke für den Sub
Ok, das ist ein Spiel, das sieht im Trailer cool aus, ist aber wahrscheinlich zu spielen, wie willst du das?
Mal gucken, man sieht da keinen richtigen Gameplay-Trailer
Das ist Call of Duty 2, ne, ne, ne, was ist das?
Ah, Stalker, natürlich, Stalker 0W
Ey, es hätte ohne Scheiß 2007, es hätte auch Call of Duty 2 sein können
Ey, 2007, nee, nee, nee, Moment, das war eher 2005
Aber Stalker 1 war cool, war richtig pock
Neko, das ist so, so soll es mal aussehen
Das finde ich, das ist kein guter Punkt, also mittlerweile versucht alles und jedes in irgendeiner Art und Weise Open World zu sein
Guckt euch in Cyberpunk an, wie sehr das nach hinten losgehen kann
Es muss nicht alles Open World sein, wichtig ist, dass es einen schlüssigen, gut spielbaren roten Faden hat
Und nur weil man ein Spiel machen will und dann Open World irgendwie dazu basteln, passt das nicht unbedingt zusammen
Ja, gut
Insofern das Spiel auch noch gut ist
Was bin ich sehen
Die müssten das scharf, das wirkt so aggressiv, wie da wieder das einspricht, weil die das irgendwie nicht richtig gefiltert haben oder so
Das ist so voll das, so scharf in der Aufnahme
Ja, hör dir das
Keine guten Aufnahmesettings
Sieht übelst langweilig aus
Stimmt, du musst erstmal eine Grafikkarte bekommen mit Trade Tracing, aber das ist ja einfach seit neuestem
Du gehst einfach auf den Preisschamp, preisschamp.org und da siehst du alle aktuellen Grafikkarten, die lieferbar sind
Und da siehst du, dass du für einen wahnsinnigen Schnapper von 1900 bis 2300 Euro sich eine Grafikkarte kaufen kannst, die normalerweise 1500 kostet
Ist das nicht nice
Handgebaut, so oder so sieht das Spiel dank der vielen Lichter und Details extrem schick aus, zumal die Umgebung sogar teilweise zerstörbar ist
Nur die Sache mit dem Trade Tracing Support steht noch nicht endgültig fest
Es muss doch nicht alles, ich mein, wenn das Spiel sackt, macht das Trade Tracing jetzt auch nicht besser, oder
Sie haben aber zumindest erklärt, dass sie die Technik gerne für ihr Spiel einsetzen würden und hey, das Ding sieht ja auch ohne Trade Tracing schon verdammt gut aus
Ratchet and Clank Rift Apart will die Power der PS5 als Exklusivtitel so richtig ausnutzen
Ja gut, müssen sie ja auch
Ich mein, die PS5 hat im Prinzip nichts, warum ich sie mir kaufen sollte, es sei denn, man möchte das Dark Souls Remake haben
Es gibt keinerlei Anreize eine PS5 zu kaufen aktuell
Schönen Ray Tracing Spiegelung bemerkbar
Davon abgesehen, es gibt sie ja auch gar nicht zu kaufen
Soll durch die neue Technologie aufgepeppt werden, die schnelle SSD der Playstation 5 macht solche Levelübergänge erst möglich und erlaubt es uns ohne Ladezeiten zwischen den Welten hin und her zu reisen
Leute, was hab ich gerade gesagt, der Chat wieder, der Chat, also heute ist er schlimm
Ich hab gerade gesagt, außer vielleicht das Dark Souls, sorry, es ist kein Dark Souls, Demons Souls Remake
Jetzt kommt der Chat, ja aber das Demons Souls Remake
Damit ist das neue Ratchet and Clank nicht nur serientypisch schick, sondern auch technisch auf mehreren Ebenen vielversprechend
Schon im März erwartet uns mit Kina Bridge of Spirits ein grafisches Highlight des Jahres, zumindest nach den bislang gezeigten Trailern zu urteilen
In einer offenen Welt erkunden wir als titelgebende Heldin das Land und bekämpfen zahlreiche Monster
Okay, also Trailer ohne Gameplay ist immer so ein Ding, du hast halt keinen blassen Schimmer, was dich erwartet
Okay, ist gekauft
Und die sogenannten Rod sollen im Gameplay auch noch verdammt nützlich sein, Pikmin lässt grüßen
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es sieht ein bisschen nach Pikmin aus
Ich gesehen überzeugt Kina vor allem durch die, sagen wir mal, Pixar Optik, bei der wir ständig das Gefühl haben in einem Animationsfilm unterwegs zu sein
Und obendrauf gibt's dichte Vegetation
Das Video geht ja auch um Grafik
Texturen und eine sehr hervorstechende Beleuchtung ist ja nicht der erste Titel mit schickem Licht in dieser Liste
Man müsste die Lautstärke zwischen Sprecher und Game Sound vielleicht ein bisschen besser machen
Wer einen Raytracing Trailer von Nvidia gesehen hat, der hat den hier sehr wahrscheinlich auch schon gesehen
Der russische Cousin der Nier Automata Roboter gehört nämlich zu Atomic Heart, einem der kommenden Spiele mit Raytracing Support
Die ambitionierte Immersive Sim im Geister eines BioShocks sieht nicht nur sehr schön aus
Das Spiel soll in aller Voraussicht nach auch noch dieses Jahr endlich für PC und Xbox Series X herauskommen
Und klar auch der Rest des Titels sieht dank des markanten Designs und der Umsetzung extrem spannend aus
Aber insbesondere die Lichtstimmung ist dank Raytracing ein echter Hingucker
Bleibt nur zu hoffen, dass das finale Spiel auch inhaltlich überzeugen kann
Ne wahrscheinlich nicht
Und etwas flüssiger als die bislang gezeigten Gameplay Szenen läuft
Wahrscheinlich nicht
Das ist ja in den letzten Jahren das Problem
Trailer ultra nice, guckt euch Anthem an Alter
Ultra nice
Und dann kommt das Spiel und du denkst dir, what the fuck
Was ist das?
Ja rapide, nice wenn du das gerne anguckst
Huge
Was ist das für, was ist das für, für rumgeballert, für ne Sounduntermalung
Genau, genau das ist der passende Soundtrack dafür ja
Die Unreal Demo
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht
Ich fand den ersten Teil ganz ok
Das war mal was anderes
Und ähm
Das hatte auch einen guten Abschluss, das braucht eigentlich keinen zweiten Teil
Zwar bietet die Fortsetzung des Überraschungshits kein Raytracing
Die neue Unreal Engine zeigt aber eindrucksvoll wie mächtig sie in den richtigen Händen sein kann
Denn das hier war alles in-game, nicht vorgerendert
Sagen zumindest die Entwickler
Eine richtige Gameplay Demo sind sie uns allerdings noch schuldig
Gut mittlerweile haben die ja richtig coole Möglichkeiten
Ich hab vergessen wie das heißt, was ist tele, telegramm, telegraphie, was auch immer
Wo du quasi Fotos von echter Umgebung nimmst und kannst die ziemlich gut im Spiel abbilden
Tele, tele
Telegrammapie, tele
Ach wie auch immer
Ihr wisst vielleicht was ich mein
Fotogrammetrie, ja das kann sein, ja das klingt gut
Inzwischen wissen wir es, Resident Evil Village erscheint bereits am 7. Mai 2021 für PC, PS4, PS5, Xbox One und Xbox Series S und X
Kann sich doch jemand an das Dorf aus Resident Evil 4 erinnern?
Ziemlich am Anfang
Die Szenen zeigen es, dieses Mal geht es in ein fiktives rumänisches Dorf samt Wälder und Schloss, in dem vermeintliche Vampire und Werwölfe ihr Unwesen treiben
Die technische Grundlage ist eine verbesserte Version der RE-Engine, die dieses Mal auch Raytracing unterstützt
Re-Engine
Aus dieser Perspektive erkunden wir auch diesmal sehr detaillierte Umgebungen, die an manchen Szenen fast schon einen fotorealistischen Eindruck hinterlassen
Und in der Maiden Demo für die PS5 lief das ganze sogar in 60 FPS und 4K Auflösung, was natürlich auf eine eindrucksvolle Vollversion hoffen lässt
Nur beim VR Support sieht es diesmal wohl düster aus
Lange waren Rennspiele die absoluten Technikvorreiter, wenn es um tolle Grafik geht
Resident Sleeper
Rennspiele
Und das nächste Gran Turismo grafisch enttäuschen
Bestimmt, bestimmt, wie sieht es mit dem nächsten Need for Speed aus?
Kappa HD
Bislang gezeigten Szenen aus beiden Titeln haben uns durchaus beeindruckt
Gerade weil beide Titel auf eine Open World verzichten und so mehr Leistung für Grafik und Simulation übrig haben
Für eindrucksvolle Licht, Schatten und Spiegelungseffekte soll zudem das Raytracing sorgen, das alle neuen Konsolen unterstützen
Forza Motorsport soll Gerüchten zufolge 2021 für PC und Xbox Series X und S, Gran Turismo 7 laut Sony für PS5 ebenfalls noch in diesem Jahr kommen
Es könnte mich fast nichts mehr langweilt als Rennspiele
Die Anfahrt der Gefühle erlebt ist Celine
Die Astronautin erlebt in Returnal nämlich den Horror, dass sie nach jedem Tod wieder erwacht und erneut gegen zahlreiche Monster kämpfen muss
Der Roguelike Titel
Manche fänden das sicherlich cool
Einfach mal easy vom Hochhaus springen, weiter gehts
Setzt dabei auf eine dichte Lichtstimmung und viele bunte Geschosse
Vor allem die zufallsbasierte Level Zusammenstellung bleibt aber spannend
Zumindest in den Trailern sieht die nämlich ziemlich organisch aus
Mal sehen ob der Shooter dann zum Release am 19. März 2021 exklusiv für PS5 auch mit besonderen Orten glänzen kann
Die vielen Effekte und Details sind aber trotz sehr dunklem Bild schon jetzt beeindruckend
Was zum... ist das für eine beknackte Musikuntermalung für diesen Trailer?
Erinnert ihr euch noch an diesen wunderbaren Spaziergang? An die herrliche Umgebung samt spannender Geschichte?
The vanishing of Ethan Carter hat schon wieder 7 Jahre auf dem Buckel
Die Macher The Astronauts werken seitdem in Witchfire
Einem ebenfalls sehr schönen aber dann doch thematisch sehr anderem Spiel aus der Ego Perspektive
Technisch bleibt das wie schon beim Titel zuvor enorm beeindruckend
Denn dank Fotogrammetrie bei der viele Ecken...
Fotogrammetrie! Das meinte ich vorhin! Fotogrammetrie! Genau!
In möglichst echt wirkenden virtuellen Objekten resultieren sieht der Shooter enorm gut aus
Und klar, auch hier ist die Lichtstimmung besonders entscheidend um die düstere Atmosphäre zu erzeugen
Ob der PC-Titel noch 2021 kommt ist leider noch nicht sicher, es wäre aber wirklich langsam mal an der Zeit
Die Macher von Black Desert Online haben bereits gezogen, dass sie hübsche Spiele entwickeln können
Mit Crimson Desert wollen sie nun Einzelspieler bedienen und gleichzeitig MMO-Inhalte wie Raids einbinden
Was witzig war, das haben die ja als MMO gestartet und jetzt irgendwie zu einem Singleplayer umgewurstet
Technisch beeindruckt das mittelalterliche Setting mit detaillierten Umgebungen
Es sieht halt aus wie BDO, ne? Okay, das sieht besser aus als BDO
Aber die Stadt könnte halt original aus BDO sein
Das mittelalterliche Setting mit detaillierten Umgebungen, scharfen Texturen und natürlich einer Beleuchtung, die von Raytracing profitiert
Wie gut der Rest wird, erfahren wir auf PC, PS5 und Xbox URS und X spätestens im Winter 2021
Zu guter Letzt soll auch Horizon for Bidden West 2021 noch exklusiv für die PS5 erscheinen
Und dass das hier technisch beeindruckend ist, das müssen wir keinem mehr sagen, oder?
Ja, aber das ist wahrscheinlich einfach pre-render
Ehrlich gesagt ist mir das scheißegal
Solange das Spiel gut und stimmig aussieht, ist mir das wurscht, ob die das mit Raytracing machen oder nicht Raytracing oder Butttracing oder was auch immer
Die können tracen, was sie wollen, wenn das stimmig aussieht und sich gut spielt, reicht mir das
Detaillierte Figuren und Roboterwesen und eindrucksvolle Lichtstimmungen werden dem Nachfolger zu Horizon Zero Dawn aber sehr wahrscheinlich zu einem grafischen Highlight des Jahres machen
Das waren einige der voraussichtlich schönsten Spiele, deren Veröffentlichung wir 2021 erwarten
Und wer bis hier hin zugeschaut hat, der wird wohl auch dezent mitbekommen haben, was uns dieses Jahr am meisten erwartet
Okay, war dann wohl doch nicht so dezent, aber Raytracing und Beleuchtung sind in diesem Jahr nun mal ein großer Punkt bei technisch anspruchsvollen Spielen
Egal ob es nun um einen Comicartigen oder realistischen Stil geht und natürlich ist Raytracing nicht alles und natürlich gibt es noch eine ganze Reihe an weiteren Titeln, die auch mit anderen Mitteln sehr gut auskommen
Stil und Design sind etwa nicht minder entscheidend, wie etwa Scorn oder Shadow Warrior 3 zeigen
Wer Shadow Warrior 3, bin ich mal gespannt, ob das was wird
Also ich fand den ersten und den zweiten echt gut
Also von den Remakes
Stilisierte Abenteuer wie Psychonauts 2 profitieren davon und wie es dann mit der vollkommenen photorealistischen Grafik aussehen könnte, zeigt Project Mara von den Hellblade Macher Ninja Theory
Aber das ist dann eine Geschichte für 2022
Und jetzt seid ihr gefragt, welche Spiele könnten für euch die schönsten 2021 werden, verratet es uns in den Kommentaren
Also die schönsten Spiele 2021 wären für mich mal wieder eins, was ich länger als drei Stunden spielen kann und immer noch Bock drauf hab
Was mich nicht zu kackt mit irgendwelchen Boxen, Microtransactions und Lootboxen, die ich nur aufmachen kann, wenn ich vorher Ingame Credits gekauft habe oder sonst was
Irgendwie einfach ein Game, wo du auch mal, keine Ahnung, 50-60 Stunden gern dran spielst und es dich nicht nervt
Das wird mir schon reichen
Also Single, ich rede jetzt von Singleplayer Spielen
Stabilisierend, wie es die ein oder andere Multiplayer Spiele gibt, kann durchaus sein
Next Level Automations in my Smart Apartment, ja zeigt mal her
Heimautomatisierungen, Stells am Start, gucken wir uns jetzt an
Oder ne, wir gucken uns, was ist eigentlich mit den Upload Filtern passiert, gucken wir uns jetzt an
Weil da hat man ja seitdem es da mit großem Tamtam entschieden wurde, nicht mehr allzu viel gehört
Jetzt knapp zwei Jahre her, seit die große Empörung rund um die Implikation der neuen Urheberrechtsrichtlinie der EU Fahrtaufnahmen
Die Umstände waren klar, die Konsequenzen dieser Richtlinie wären aufgrund unmöglicher technischer Umsetzbarkeit, massenhafte Sperrung legaler Inhalte im Internet
Ein Risiko, das man offenbar bereit war einzugehen
Kurz bevor das EU-Parlament im März 2019
Oh nein, Dings hier
Der Dude, Alter
Wie hieß er nochmal?
Axel Voss, genau
Die Richtlinie beschließt, spricht Federführer Axel Voss naiv
Ja, Axel Voss
Der hat sich unbeliebt gemacht
Die betroffenen Plattformen hätten ja noch zwei Jahre Zeit, die technischen Notwendigkeiten zu entwickeln
Sicher, ich mach mir jetzt auch schon mal einen Termin fürs Klon, bis nächste Woche kriegt ihr das hier alle gewuppt, oder?
Jetzt, kurz vor Ablauf dieser Zeit, lohnt es sich, einmal zurückzuschauen und zu gucken, was sich seitdem eigentlich alles getan hat
und wie es jetzt um die so gefürchteten Uploadfilter steht
Seitdem die Richtlinie verabschiedet wurde, sind die Mitgliedsstaaten der EU dazu verpflichtet, bis zum 7. Juni 2021 ein nationales Gesetz einzuführen, das den Regelungen der Richtlinie entspricht
Alles läuft auf dieses Datum hinaus
Naja, fast alles, aber mehr dazu gleich
Die Richtlinie wird also Ende März 2019 im EU-Parlament verabschiedet und zwei Wochen später im Europäischen Rat durch die Mitgliedsstaaten nochmals bestätigt und damit restlos auf den Weg gebracht
Dafür stimmten unter anderem Länder wie Deutschland, yay, und das Vereinigte Königreich, dagegen Länder wie die Niederlande oder Polen
Und Polen scheint mit der Stimmung im Raum so gar nicht zufrieden, denn nur neun Tage später trudelt ein Brief vom polnischen Staat beim Europäischen Gerichtshof ein
Eine Klage gegen die Richtlinie, im speziellen gegen Artikel 17, damals noch Artikel 13, der Teil mit den Uploadfiltern
Laut der Klage sei die Urheberrechtsrichtlinie eine unverhältnismäßige Maßnahme, die Zensur fördere und die Meinungsfreiheit gefährde
Ja, da haben die nicht unrecht
Schutz für Rechteinhaber auf der einen Seite und den Interessen der EU-Bevölkerung auf der anderen sei völlig aus dem Gleichgewicht
Hauptmeier, Twitch bleiben, danke schön für den Zap
Und macht einen Termin zur Anhörung mit Polen irgendwann nächstes Jahr
In der Zwischenzeit rauchen in den Mitgliedsstaaten die Schreibmaschinen, denn schließlich muss ein Gesetz her, am besten noch ein brauchbares
Und aus dem von der EU angelieferten Sandstein lässt sich keine besonders stabile Hütte bauen
So vergehen ganze sieben Monate, bis das Bundesministerium für Justiz und Verbraucherschutz einen ersten Entwurf für ein nationales Gesetz veröffentlicht
Jedoch bisher ohne einen Umsetzungsversuch von Artikel 17, stattdessen größtenteils zum Leistungsschutzrecht, also der Regelung, das Google und Co fortan fürs Verlinken von News-Artikeln Geld an Verlage zahlen
Ey, Alter, da haben sie ja auch wieder was überlegt, ne?
Der Entwurf erntet eine Menge
Google hat ja dann gesagt, gut, das fand ich ja so witzig damals, wo die gesagt haben, ne ne Google, ihr müsst das bezahlen
Und hat Google gesagt, ja gut, dann verlinken wir euch einfach nicht mehr
Und daraufhin war die Big-Brain-Ausrede der Verlage so nach dem Motto, ne ne, uns einfach nicht verlinken dürft ihr auch nicht, weil damit missbraucht ihr ja eure Stellung
Also die wollten quasi, YouTube verbieten sie nicht zu verlinken und für die Links Geld zu bezahlen
Das ist auch ne geile Taktik gewesen, ne?
Nicht YouTube, ich hab YouTube, vielleicht mein Google
Das ist so groß wie ne Twitch-Emout
Ja, das stimmt
The fuck?
Laufbildes, sind das irgendwie Begriffe aus dem letzten Jahrtausend?
Das ist so groß wie ne Twitch-Emout
Ja, das muss natürlich noch alles bisschen schwammiger werden, sodass am Ende wieder keiner weiß, was Sache ist
Leute, ihr habt einen Job, macht den halt mal ordentlich
Oh, leaked
Können wir den Scheiß nicht einfach sein lassen?
Das will außer Stonks, Musikindustrie, Verlage und sonst was, keiner der noch normal im Kopf, das will das
Noch nicht mal Künstler wollen das in dem Umfang
Teure Echtzeit-Software wie beispielsweise 5000 Inder, wenn man sich nämlich mal die Google Content-Sachen anguckt, dann sind das zum größten Teil eben 5000 Inder, die das kontrollieren
Wie? Und ich wurde nicht gefragt, Anzeige ist raus
Ja, das stimmt, da haben sie recht, da haben sie recht
Ja, um jetzt
Moment, wäre es nicht sinnvoll, das erst vorher mal ordentlich zu klären, bevor man was einführt, was man vielleicht gar nicht machen darf, dann so, irgendwie komisch, oder?
Alter, das ist so ein bloated Apparat, diese ganze Geschichte, das ist der Wahnsinn
Ja
Alter, das ist so ein bloated Geldverbrennungsverein, alles der Wahnsinn
Und im Endeffekt kommt da noch was, was so nicht mal jemand haben will
Sucked
So, wir gucken uns jetzt ein bisschen entspannter Heimautomatisierungssache an
Was sehe ich da? Das ist ein Fernseher von hinten, wo was von Whirlpool drauf steht
Warum heißt das Ding Mutter? Der Mutter Fast Charge Mutter
Ja, sowas habe ich mir auch schon mal überlegt, aber ich wusste dann nicht, was ich machen soll damit
Guck mal, der hat Home Assistant am Start, beste, beste, beste Idee, die er da hatte bisher
Vorher hat er nämlich immer mit 30 Milliarden Apps rumhantiert
Ich habe mir das auch schon überlegt, ob ich mir irgendwie so, also nach dem Motto, ich stehe auf und dann kriege ich irgendwie so einen Morgenreport geschickt, aber mir ist nichts sinnvolles eingefallen, deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ok, wenn dir schon nichts sinnvolles einfällt, ist es vielleicht gar nichts sinnvolles zu machen
Ja, aber brauch ich nicht
Das ist übrigens nice, sowas will ich mir die ganze Zeit auch schon holen, so ein Drucksensor, das man erkennt, wenn man im Bett ist und wenn nicht
Da gibt es so Matten, die legt man drunter und die erkennen dann, wenn Gewicht drauf ist
Da kann man so nicht sagen, ich habe zum Beispiel NFC Tag, wenn ich aufs Klo gehe und halte das Handy an, NFC Tag geht der Heizlüfter morgens an oder im Wohnzimmer geht das Licht beispielsweise nach 22 Uhr aus, nach 15 Minuten, wenn der Fernseher ausgeschaltet wurde und sowas
Es gibt schon ein paar ganz coole Dinge, oder ich kriege beispielsweise mit einer Lampe die Bahnverspätung angezeigt, es gibt schon ein paar ganz coole Dinge, oder beispielsweise ich kriege eine Warnung, wenn ich meinen Fischteich zudenken muss, weil er gefriert und so, man kann schon ein paar sinnvolle Sachen machen
Ne Reed, auf Katze, also entweder bist du ultra leicht, entweder wiegst du nur 10 Kilo oder so, dass es dich mit der Katze verwechselt oder irgendwie stimmt da was nicht
Aber in Familie gibt es keinen Alexa, ich würde aber ja auch keinen Alexa in die Wohnung stellen
Anzeige ist raus, ne, sobald, wenn die nicht daheim sind und es mit Motion detected muss direkt die Polizei kommen, direkt anrücken und gleich alles, alles äh
Wegbashen
Oder Moment, war der in den USA oder war der in Kanada der Typ, wenn er in den USA ist noch einfacher, wenn die nicht daheim sind, einfach Selbstschussanlage an das Tor, weil alles was unerlaubt auf mein Grundstück kommt, wird Kokona Style weggeballert
Das ist doch mal, das ist der wahre Kokona Way
Klemos, genau Klemos, vor der Haustür werden scharf gemacht
Das ist sinnvoll, nervt wahrscheinlich
Okay, das stelle ich mir cool vor, wenn man wirklich viel Musik hört
Ich habe ja meistens meinen Kopfhörer auf und habe da ein bisschen Playlist im Hintergrund laufen, aber auch will ich auch nur, wenn ich vorm Rechner sitze
Aber wenn man den ganzen Tag gedudel im Hintergrund haben will, dann ist es sicherlich cool, wenn die Lautsprecher einem durch die Wohnung folgen, wo man gerade ist
Warum genau ist es wichtig, dass die Küche, wenn keiner drin ist, Licht hat?
Echt? Wieso?
Dann muss man sich den Kram ja anhören, den die Leute erzählen
Was hat er gerade gesagt?
Wie kann ein NFC Tag strong sein? Das ist rein passiv das Ding
Also, es hat selbst keine eigene Energiequelle drin, sagen wir so
Größere Spule hier, das kann man machen
Also ich erkenne, wenn der Fernseher an und aus ist, ganz einfach, ich habe hier ein Shield TV dran und ich frage einfach über Home Assistant, Home Assistant hat eine Android Google Player Integration, fragt mich nicht, wie das Ding genau heißt
Und daran kann ich erkennen, ob das Shield TV gerade an oder aus ist, beziehungsweise ob etwas abgespielt wird oder nicht, ich habe es so eingestellt, wenn es nach 22 Uhr ist und der Fernseher ausgeschaltet wird, beziehungsweise Playing Stopped
Nach 22 Uhr und dann schaltet er 15 Minuten später die Heizung runter und die Lichter aus und macht den Fernseher aus, also es reicht, wenn man Stop drückt oder den Fernseher aus, macht es egal, dann macht der Heizung runter, Licht aus und Fernseher aus nach einer Viertelstunde
Wenn man weiter abspielt, dann klappt es an
Gute Idee
Das ist eine ziemlich gute Idee, das ist eine ziemlich gute Idee, wenn man das mit NFC Tags macht, dass der dann anhand der Tageszeit dann, wobei man muss es ja nicht mit NFC Tags machen, es geht ja mit normalen Schaltern auch, wenn es halt Smart Dinger sind, dass es über den Hub geht, dass man die Beleuchtung anhand der Tageszeit macht, finde ich das eine coole Idee
Benutzt du manchmal einen VPN? Naja, nur wenn ich wirklich irgendwelche Geo Sachen faken muss, wie beispielsweise irgendein Spiel früher runterladen kann aus Korea oder so, aber ansonsten eigentlich nicht
Regeret
Das ist übrigens die gleiche Heimautomatisierung, die ich auch am Start habe, das ist eigentlich, finde ich, mit das Beste, was es gibt, Home Assistant ist echt top
Was ist die einfachste Variante, unter Linux eine IP aus Indien zu bekommen oder vielleicht sogar mit einem Proxy oder so
Ne, wisst ihr was ich mache? Ich hole mir einfach einen Server, in Indien macht X-Forwarding im Browser, da brauch ich auch nicht mal einen VPN
Und danach kann ich wieder löschen, das ist sogar noch billiger
Ja, dem Dennis, da musst du halt Sachen nehmen, die dir wirklich was bringen, ich würde nicht Dinger machen, das sehe ich genauso übrigens, ich würde nicht Dinger machen, einfach nur weil sie cool sind und gehen und es komplizierter macht, es sollte letztendlich unterm Strich das sein, was einem auf den Kicks geht, dass man weniger davon machen muss
So habe ich das bei mir auch gemacht
Anzeige ist raus
Er sollte bei Home Assistant bleiben, weil Home Assistant einfach beste ist
Ich muss mal kurz was gucken
Leute, Leute, ich muss mal ganz schnell rüber mein Handy holen, ich will mich jetzt nämlich mal schnell bei Digital Ocean einloggen und gucken, ob man indische Server mieten kann
So, alles Leute wieder am Start
Ich mach das mal kurz im Stream, da könnt ihr mitgucken
Mach ich mal meine VM an, weil wenn man sich da indische Server mieten kann, dann ist das viel einfacher als mit dem VPN
So, Poggers starten
Der Channel hier, Smart Home Solver heißt der Typ, der macht wirklich ganz gute Smart Home Videos, da sind viele Ideen, wo ich sage, was ein Schwachsinn ist, aber das ist ja eine individuelle Geschichte
Warum Indien, weil es in Indien YouTube Premium für 1,49 gibt
Ok, machen wir mal hier, Private
Muss mal kurz gucken, was mein Passport ist
Ach du Scheiße
Ich machs einfach in Windows
Digital Ocean login
So, was kostet die indische Sign In?
Ich muss euch ausmachen Leute, ihr dürft das jetzt nicht sehen
Kein Quake
So, 6-digit Code
No Leak, nein heute kein Leak
Mittlerweile ist es ja keine 2 Factor Authentifizierung mehr, sondern gefühlt 80 Factor Authentifizierung
Weil ihr gar nicht genau weißt, wo du überall was nachgucken musst und starten musst
Ok, jetzt kann ich euch wieder anmachen
Also, start with a droplet, so kann man da Indien auswählen, wo ist Standort?
Bangalore, ist das in Indien?
Das ist das Indien? Bangalore?
Bangaluru
Bundesstaat Karnat, ok das ist Indien, exzellent, exzellent, also
Was 5,38 Euro kostet das jetzt in Indien? Wirklich? Was soll das? Anzeige ist raus
Wie? Cacquade? Warum?
Ich gucke jetzt was es kostet, ich gucke jetzt was es kostet, ok, wir machen einen Server, nein, nein, nein, 5 Euro, 5 Euro, bla, bla, bla, Ubuntu, klar, SSH Key
Create
So, dann loggen wir uns jetzt gleich ein
Onstream, ich gucke jetzt was es kostet, ja, ja, ich gucke jetzt was es kostet, ist ja kein Ding
Ich brauche nur die LP von dem Teil, dass ich mich einloggen kann
Hacker Man, Hacker Man Action, ja, ja
Dann gucken wir gleich weiter, ich will jetzt wissen was Youtube Premium kostet auf in Indien
Da ist der Hetzner schneller mit dem Erstellen
Guckt daran, erkennt ihr, wir haben eine CPU, 1G Anbindung in Blr, das ist das Bangalore
Bangalore, ich weiß gar nicht wie man das ausspricht, indische Stadt
Was passiert ist, wir haben uns gerade eine VM in Indien erstellt, eine Linux Kiste in Indien, so, hier, IP, excellent, copied
SSH, root, add, bam, yes
Oh, die Verbindung nach Indien ist ja erstklassig
Alter, das leckt, as fuck, was haben wir da für einen Ping hin
Okay, das ist nicht so geil
150er Ping, ey, ich darf nichts sagen, mit dem 150er Ping hat man früher auch CS gespielt über Modem, gar kein Problem
Ich kann doch nicht mal ein Update machen, Alter
Standard Curry-Leitung
VPA in Indien nutzen, Small Brain, VM in Indien erstellen, Big Brain, ja, ist so, ist so
So, und jetzt installieren wir einfach einen Browser, einen Browser, einen Broser
Und dann machen wir X-Forwarding und gucken mal was Youtube Premium, was war die Seite, Youtube Premium
Jaja, geh weg
Alles, das gucken wir uns jetzt gleich, also das hier ist die lokale Youtube Premium-Seite, nur zur Erklärung
Also, das ist Youtube Premium bei uns
Und jetzt gucken wir uns gleich, warum sieht das eigentlich so kacke aus
Und jetzt gucken wir uns gleich Youtube Premium in Indien an
Dazu muss ich aber erstmal ein Update auf dem Server machen, man weiß ja nie, was da alles am Start ist
Was ich mache, ich hab mir einen indischen, ich hab mir einen indischen, 12 Euro kostet das Scheiß in Deutschland
Ich hab mir einen indischen, äh, eine indische VM erstellen und gucke, ob man Youtube Premium darüber kaufen kann
Satt Uplink 2 Sekunden, ja, das ist krass, das ist hart
Ich hab auch das Gefühl, das Update ist lahm in Indien
Guckt euch das mal an, das geht ja kaum vorwärts, was macht das da so lang
Die Hetzler Kiste wäre schon seit 5 Minuten dreimal, dreimal Rebooted und alles drauf
Was bringt Youtube Premium, dass man keine Werbung mehr sich angucken muss
Und wenn man iOS benutzt, wenn man ein iPhone hat, kommst du ja nicht drum herum
Weil es da keinen, keinen gescheiten Adblocker für Youtube gibt
Es sei denn, du guckst über Safari und YouTube über Safari zackt halt mal richtig
Piehall bringt nix
Was zum Teufel wollen die von mir
Was ist mit Digital Ocean los, ich will einfach nur das Ding updaten
Nee, gibt's nicht für iOS, nope, wie wärs mit Werbung schauen
Nee, vor allem nicht wenn ich abends im Bett lieg und pennen will und auf einmal kommt dann irgendwie die Scooter Werbung von Strato oder so
Ich bringe denen schon genug Geld
Auf, mach mal fertig, ich muss jetzt ein Chrome installieren, Chrome öffnen und gut ist, mach hinne
Exzellent, VM in Indien, mach hin
Einfach Jailprank, nope
Ja, E-Scooter hab ich mir nicht bestellt, nee, auf Update, mach hinne
Komm Indische VM, gib alles
Dabei ist das nur das System Update, ich hab jetzt nicht gedacht, dass das so lang dauert
Pause Jam, auf, jawoll, oh nee jetzt wird der Colonel noch, ja dann
Oh die Musik, exquisit Hackermann Musik
Jetzt gucken wir uns als nächstes an
Der 8 Euro Minecraft Pitz, oh Gott, das Ding sieht aus wie was, was ich mal vor 15 Jahren hatte
Danach gucken wir uns eine Runde Black Cops an, easy
So, oh, okay, Up, install, Chrome, Chromium, Moment ist Chromium unter Ubuntu, Firefox ist besser
Chrome, Chrome unter, Chrome unter Ubuntu ist doch Snap, oder?
Dann installieren wir lieber Firefox
Snap, Alter, was soll das, ey, was soll das?
Snap, Alter, was soll das, der reudigste Dinger überhaupt, eh
Snap, Snap ist so extremer Pains Jam, ich hab dort net über Snap installiert
Und seitdem kann ich keine Selfcontain Anwendungen mehr bauen, die überall laufen, weil Snap sackt
ja snap ist wirklich pains champ pains champ hoch pains champ ist das also
jetzt haben wir firefox am start zack moment
y ok also firefox let's go indischer indisches youtube
oh das geht ja schon sehr schnell x-formel ding nach indien
ach so moment kann das sein dass es rumspackt wenn ich den lokalen firefox auf hab das spinnt
dann manchmal ein bisschen
auf öffne dich geh auf firefox hat das so bunto ein x-server du brauchst kein x-server
du brauchst nur x-orth und x-formel ding aktivieren
der macht einfach nix hallo firefox jetzt jetzt macht er was heute auf jetzt
kommen kommen firefox gibt's mir hau hau
highspeed highspeed übertragung aus indien viel slack man
und und und ok das machen wir gleich zu gleich gleich schließen gleich schließen
das ist ja huge huge speed huge speed massive massive geschwindigkeit
ja das war für fünf euro die vm ich glaube aber eher die latenz ist in dem fall das problem
auch immer hat mein klick schon registriert er hat mein klick schon registriert aber ich
habe eine andere idee wir brechen es nochmal ab wir machen wir machen compression noch an
vielleicht geht es dann schneller und es noch mal auf let's go firefox ich hoffe jetzt geht
schneller minutes per frame ja einfach gaming fauper nach was vpm ist für noobs fau server
in indien und dann über x-formel ding machen so machen die prostas ja ja minus zs compression
kifke in 15 monat das ist schon hyper subscription hier firefox please gib's mir
vpn ist für noobs so sieht es aus die it prost mieten sich eine vm in indien und gehen an px
vor über den drauf habt ihr gesehen der kurs hat schon geplinkt leute leute der kurs hat geplinkt ich
kann jetzt gleich was tippen es tut es tut sich was ok youtube premium it's happening it's happening
leute postchamp
kann man das hier wegklicken und es war keine gute idee das wegzuklicken
wegklicken alter was nick ok exquisite ok youtube premium mal guckt euch mal an wie
lange das braucht bis es registriert dass da eine hand ist aha aha klick
gucken was youtube premium in indien kostet
ok kostet 129 ok was ist das in euro in indische rupien in euro 1 euro 46 kostet indien
150 excellent ok nice das wird pain das wird pain in die erstes darüber zu bestellen aber
es wird funktionieren ich habe ich habe auch meinen account in wenz angemeldet allerdings
mein privaten fake account weiß kann man auch einfach kann man auch einfach für sagen wir
mal zwei jahre bezahlen und seine ruhe haben ok nice funktioniert leute was habt ihr gesagt ich
soll mal ein speed test machen habe ich das richtig verstanden ja speed test ist das speed
test haben wir da irgendwie speed speed test zl excellent warum jetzt dort 139 129 ja gute
frage gut weil die manns liebs manns lieb viel kostet also wenn ich monatliche subscription
mach kostet 129 ok also speed test aus indien speed test zl aus indien auf gehts bengaluru
von indien nach indien ist das durchaus in ordnung drei millisekunden ping download upload
also von indien nach indien ist es durchaus ok nur von hier nach indien sagt halt ein bisschen ok
nice also hier drüber könnt ihr es kommen leute ihr müsst zugeben es ist einfacher gewesen als
vpn sich jetzt rauszusuchen es ist halt es ist halt ein bisschen eklig zu bedienen aber es
funktioniert es ist so es ist einfacher no limit x o dankeschön neun monate ok cool warum ist
es jetzt nicht aufgeploppt gut kann ich kann ich später machen ich meine wir können es
natürlich richtig nice machen jetzt dann einen wire guard vpn installieren hallo please einfach
aufgehen wenn ich da drauf klicke hier in den wire guard installieren und dann über wire garter
youtube what is happening ich glaube wir müssen es einfach kleiner machen dann ist schneller
kommt mal wir machen es einfach nur so excellent muss nicht so viel übertragen
die wollen mein money nicht ja sieht so aus er muss der browser muss reload jetzt jetzt keine
so gute idee ja kein patch die könnte man auch machen allerdings bräuchte ich dann ein proxy
wahrscheinlich dort drauf ok jetzt ist ripp richtig flutscht hier gut aber wir wissen jetzt es würde
kosten 1 euro 46 vielleicht mache ich das später ein browser heute mein browser ist weg er ist noch
da hier ist er man sieht die plus nicht alles klar ok sehr gut sehr gut haben ausprobiert zack zack
und jetzt zeige ich euch mal was das richtig geile an so cloud geschichten ist jetzt das hat mich
jetzt 50 5 cent oder so gekostet und jetzt wirds ding einfach gelöscht zack und es hat mich jetzt
keine ahnung 0,05 cent oder so gekostet zum ausprobieren so excellent weiter gucken wieso
kostet es bei mir fünf euro in indien das weiß ich nicht keine ahnung bei mir hat es 129 schrub
jen gekostet ok was ist das hier zeigt mal ja ok leute was gucken wir uns als nächstes an also
sie haben zur auswahl 8 euro minecraft pc hans showdown warum windows 95 1111 an valid key ist ich
weiß nicht wie spannend das ist irgendwelche komischen laser black ops 1 speedrun oder das
20 euro das bekommen wir gucken wir gucken mal kurz das flip phone an für 20 euro machen wir
gleich ich will aber noch mal durch durch durch skippen warum das überhaupt ein ding ist
oh was hat er denn ok excellent excellent mit dem steuerkreuz im steuerkreuz die maus
bewegen das ist natürlich richtig nice das das track track track phone track phone kann man
gar nicht ausbrechen huge display ist ungefähr so ein großes display wie ne smartwatch 20 dollar
yeah 20 dollars for this phone and i always thought these because i mean i had seen phones like these before and i always just said oh you know
yeah it's gonna allow you to call and send text messages very very videos and that phone airtime
model which again has aside from bringing your own videos and brows my flip to a micro sd card
was nicht mal apple hinkriegt für 1500 euro smartphone charger micro usb oder war das
ganz kurz gesehen war das ein micro usb das ist ein micro usb sagt ihr leute micro usb usb 10
micro usb würde ich sagen das ist ein micro usb und you're also going to get your track phone
this is how the actual phone service on this with track phone you've got your imia and stuff on the back here ok firefox us das gibt es noch so was yeah that was a you know short lived i think pretty short lived da sieht man so wieder das was ich letztens mal gesagt firefox ist seit jahren dabei sich selbst zu zerstören
system created by mozilla and it was mozilla's attempt to get in on the smartphone game so this is based off of a fork an open source fork of that project it is still based on linux which android is too so there are going to be some similarities but yes there are pre-installed applications we are going to take a look at youtube that is going to be one of the major focuses of this video what are you kidding me there's a mouse pointer no way oh my god no way it's a mouse pointer
that is beautiful i was not you can move it one you got to press the the button to move like it would one pixel over oh my okay so we're going to get this search that is
google das die leute firefox verwenden statt chrome und das hilft auch nicht das hilft die bekommen nicht genug geld von google die bekommen nur genug geld von google wenn ihr browser weiterhin verbreitet ist und die sorgen ja gerade dafür dass das gegenteil der fall ist zum beispiel dass sie ihre ganzen add-on support eingestellt haben richtig fail die grote riesen vorteil von firefox war der bessere add-on die besseren add-on möglichkeiten im vergleich zu chrome und ja hat man abgeschafft
wir können wir können wir sagen also lassen wir das mikrofon erlauben michael mj d nein dann firefox add-ons gehen seit glaub firefox 68 oder oder 48 ich weiß es nicht mehr genau gehen nicht mehr es geht nur diese neue art von add-ons und die können viel weniger als die alten add-ons die haben einfach die alte add-on schrittstelle abgeschaltet
but this is i mean this appears to be like a this honestly looks like the youtube mobile site i don't know what this video is but that's a great thumbnail wow mikrofon das ist bestimmt die youtube mobile seite
well thankfully you can search no script das alte no script war das beste that is really really great but es gibt kein es gibt kein es gibt keinen offiziellen windows chromium es gibt nur custom builds guck dir das alte no script an und guck dir das neue an oder vergleicht mit ublock oder so das alte no script war einfach das geilste du konntest es so detailliert einstellen und es war letztendlich danach nicht mehr möglich
okay so let's go ahead and uh michael mj d
okay here it is so there's my funktioniert will move the mouse pointer down the click on it und guck dir diese scheiß bedienung an diese hingekriegt haben die jetzt auf dem desktop so ist wie eine tablet bedienung dass die beispielsweise ihren 264 die code auf android rausgeworfen haben und firefox macht ganz viel merkwürdige dinger es reicht nicht einfach nur firefox zu sein man muss die sachen eigentlich in den bereichen was sie gut gemacht hat besser machen als google
dass die leute firefox verwendet es gibt wenig gründe firefox zu verwenden aktuell der einzige grund ist die in manchen bereichen vielleicht noch ein bisschen besseren entwickler tools aber warum sollte ich sonst firefox verwenden das einzige warum ich noch ab und zu mal firefox sein ist weil die suchleiste immer noch deutlich besser ist als von chrome aber ansonsten
dann macht firefox auch immer neue dinge und stellt sie wieder ein ich meine es läuft ich meine es hat eine auflösung wie aus 1998 aber es läuft auf ein 20 euro smartphone ja ihr seid aber einer der ganz wenigen die es verwenden weil es nicht google ist die meisten leute interessiert das auch nicht das hieß so daran dass die meisten leute whatsapp verwenden
not bad i got to say i mean obviously it's kind of awkward to like hold the phone like this i mean you can't fold this back or anything so you just kind of like have to you know the phone like this with your headphones in so here's how you can watch it in portrait so you have a firefox macht nur so dinger dann sollten sie vielleicht sich überlegen ok wenn wir schon fünf sachen versucht haben und die sind in die hose gegangen sollten wir uns vielleicht mal auf das konzentrieren was uns ausgemacht hat dass wir einen guten entdeckungsbar enthousiasten browser machen
den aber auch mainstream leute verwenden können alter wie das leckt
so yeah i mean that's how you can watch youtube videos on this 20 dollar smartphone just with this really bizarre like mouse pointer like interface it's just i find this hilarious but okay so this menu button right here when you tap that or press the button these are app specific settings right here and i apologize for the screen the most high quality screen doesn't really work the most high quality screen doesn't really work enthousiastenprodukte bringen kein geld firefox aktuell ist auch total auf absteigender ast
die das ist ja grad die haben es verkackt firefox war beliebt bei enthousiasten und vielleicht ein bisschen interessierten interessierten noobs und halt auch leute die sich einfach nur einen guten browser haben wollten ja aber mittlerweile sind die nix halbes und nix ganzes es gibt keinen grund mehr weder für die 08 also kaum noch ein für die 0815 user firefox anstatt chrome zu verwenden und für den enthousiasten benutzer immer weniger also insofern man muss sich nicht wundern wie sich der marktbar browser entwickelt hat firefox hat es massiv verkackt einfach die letzten jahre
man darf ja nicht vergessen man darf ja nicht vergessen firefox ist hatte mehr als chrome firefox war richtig big for chrome
ich glaube lighthouse haben sie sowas haben sie glaubt nicht ne firefox war richtig big for chrome also sprich die mussten ja erstmal überholt werden es ist zum beispiel auch so ein ding wie ewig das gedauert hat bis hardware decoding unter linux funktioniert ja klar kann man sagen gut wen interessiert hardware decoding gerade schon unter linux aber das waren halt die dinger die dazu
geführt haben dass eben firefox beliebt war bei leuten die sie ein bisschen für bisschen für technik interessiert haben du hattest oftmals sachen in firefox vorreiter geschichten auch was standards anging die add-on möglichkeiten den best aber es gibt nix mehr davon
firefox hat nichts anderes übrig außer google startseite zu verwenden aber warum sollte sich jemand google chrome installieren wenn er zufrieden ist mit firefox ausprobieren und dann sagen ich steige jetzt um der schritt umzusteigen ist immer das problem
sobald das produkt jetzt vielleicht nur ähnlich ist oder so da gibt es keinen grund aber die leute fanden chrome aktiv besser als firefox deswegen hat chrome auch so viel aufgeholt natürlich darf man nicht vergessen dass das default unter android ist
und weil die ganzen google surfaces schön integriert sind dass du android sinken kannst mit deinem desktop browser sinken kannst und sonstige geschichten und weil es firefox auch massiv verschissen hat
die haben ihre alten plugin schrittstellen abgeschaltet die haben irgendwie so ein komisches touch basiertes guckt euch das mal an ich mein chrome kannst du irgendwie noch halbwegs bedienen im desktop modus wenn du willst ja aber firefox ist ja wirklich mit diesem komischen menü hier und diesen unterding absolute zumutung ey
und die machen auch nichts innovatives die letzten jahre mehr wo du sagen kannst ja das ist was wofür ich firefox verwenden würde als browser also den einzigen grund warum ich firefox noch verwenden ist manchmal die devtools und weil die adressleiste einfach besser ist als die chrome immer noch
das ist das ist eine gute frage das ist eine gute frage hier also ob da wirklich was dran ist kann natürlich keiner was sagen ist an diesem mythos was dran provider drosseln also ich glaube offiziell wird das keiner wird das keiner zugeben von den providers die telekom ist bekannt dafür dass sie
ein ultraschlechtes peering hat zu welchem provider auch immer man muss für youtube schon seit jahren also abends auf telekom youtube ist teilweise ganz ätzend wenn es mit youtube dl geht ist ja ist die frage ich könnte mir das schon vorstellen dass gewisse
dinger abends getrosselt werden damit die anderen sachen besser funktionieren zugeben wird es wahrscheinlich keiner aber wenn es eng wird willst du machen aber ob da was dran ist kann dir keiner so genau sagen
ich meine für 20 euro Leute für 20 euro geht das ding noch vollkommen in ordnung oder
ja
ja exzellent
ok ich bin long press i really like this voice thing because that makes like i have even had to use the correct or so oh yeah i mean i've never 20 euro geht es voll in ordnung
ein kiosk device before email can you like if i were to put in a gmail like i wonder if this if you can sign like that oh hey that's surprising oh setting up account oh no you can sign in okay that's surprising so you can sign in
ja noch geht es nicht oh es lebt
dass das überhaupt videos abspielen kann wo wir wieder sehen dass in jedem furz mittlerweile hat 264 die cola drin ist
sp würdest du denn empfehlen tja letztendlich das was bei dir am besten ist lokal gibt es nix kannst du kannst weder wundervo noch telekom wirklich großartig empfehlen neben das was bei dir lokal das beste preis leistungsverhältnis hat und
gut es ist ein fm radio i won't be able to do this because obviously there's going to be copyrighted music und die media gibt es nicht mehr aber das ist
war es waren sie die video ist
aussieht das sieht aus wie die alten russischen dashcam videos die hatten auch so eine kack auflösung und das saut auch aber ok ich meine für 20 euro was willst du sagen ja und das jetzt ab
Und das jetzt abscalen auf 4K.
So, ich denke, ich werde diese Kamera für alle meine Zukunftsvideos benutzen. Was denkt ihr? Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht die beste Idee. Aber da ist es, da sind meine Floppy disks hier, ich habe meine Kamera, ich habe meinen Mikrofon, der wunderbare Charger da drüben. Und ich bin wahrscheinlich einen guten Fuß entfernt von dem Handy, also ich weiß nicht, wo der Mikrofon ist.
Das ist wirklich schlecht. Ja, genau, so sahen damals Handyvideos zu meiner Zeit noch aus. Zu meiner Schulzeit.
Aber ganz ehrlich, für 20 Euro kannst du noch nichts sagen.
Also für 20 Euro kannst du dich da nicht beschweren. Benutzen wir es jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht, weil es abfuckt direkt. Aber ja, es ist doch eigentlich ganz okay für 20 Euro.
Okay, was habe ich gesagt? Sollen wir gucken? Leute, ich habe es vergessen. Was sollten wir gucken? Ich habe gesagt, wir gucken jetzt gleich das Video, was ihr wolltet. Aber was? Minecraft PC? Nein, nein. Black Cops? Ja, was denn nun? Minecraft PC. Ja. Laser. Laser wolltet ihr. Ja, genau, Laser. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das Video ist, das wurde mir vorhin vorgeschlagen.
Okay, ich skippe das mal schnell. Laser. Okay, das ist das, ich glaube, das ist eher so ein, so ein haha funny YouTube. Oder taugt das? Der Typ ist pock. Okay, wenn der Chat das sagt.
Ich meine, wenn das medizinische Treatment nicht schrecklich genug war, dann machen wir es mit einem Mystery-Device, das mit nichts zu den Sicherheitsregeln hergestellt wurde. Das ist ein großer Knopf.
Also ja, probieren wir das mal zu Hause.
Okay, fangen wir mit diesem hier an. Das ist die Niedsel-Laser.
Das ist eine tolle All-in-One-Kosmetik-Device.
Wahrscheinlich hast du danach einen Brandfleck.
Also.
Das Ding sieht echt billig aus, ja. So als hätten sie Teile von einem alten Föhn genommen oder so und was Neues draus gebaut.
Genau, mit diesem Ding tauscht du deine Tattoos gegen Hautkrebs. Genau das, was man haben will.
Wow. Wow.
Oh, habt ihr gesehen, wie das brennt? Der Tisch hat gebrannt.
Davon kriegst du kein Hautkrebs, davon kriegst du Brandflecken.
Guck mal, der Tisch brennt.
Was willst du dir noch nicht auf die Haut machen?
Warum piepst das so doof?
Das willst du dir wahrscheinlich nicht auf die Haut machen, ne?
Aber gut, ich meine, was interessiert es den China-Hersteller?
Also, du hast im Prinzip damit die Auswahl, du tauschst Tattoos gegen Hautkrebs oder gegen Verbrennung. Alles klar.
Ja, ja.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Was ist das? Das sieht aus, das sieht aus wie so eine Brille, wo du so Augen vorne drauf pappst oder so oder so eine billige Taucherbrille oder was?
Das ist einfach nur schwarz.
Da siehst du doch gar, da siehst du nichts durch.
Okay, ich hoffe, damit behandelt keiner irgendwelche Leute.
Hat er einen Link zu AliExpress?
Guck mal, was das Ding für eine Powerheit hat.
Wie viele Bewertungen sieht man irgendwo, was das für eine Bewertung hat auf Ali?
Das garantiert AliExpress, das ist so ein typisches China-Ding.
Man sieht keine Bewertung. Nee, das ist Ebay, das ist gar nicht AliExpress, das ist Ebay.
Diese China, oh die Leute, oh please, das hat nicht wirklich jemand ausprobiert, oder?
Bevor ich das bei mir auf die Haut machen würde, würde ich es mal zumindest gegen irgendwie ein Stück Holz richten oder so.
Das ist, das ist, das ist...
Schon wieder! Hat er das nicht am Anfang schon gemacht?
Surfshark's clean web service is for bypassing throttling all when up at this.
No problem. I'll just use Surfshark to virtually advertise to do pretty much the same thing as the last laser.
Except this one's ten times more expensive and obviously a lot bigger.
I've already made an entire video on this ridiculous system in the past.
But since this is a video on sketchy DIY medical lasers, I'm obligated to break this thing out again.
There's a lot more to this kit than the last one.
Das sieht schon mal ein wenig professioneller aus als das alte.
...from the power supply. Then you have all this other gear here.
You got a footswitch here. You got these tips here that change the laser's output color.
You got some actual operator goggles as well as the patient goggles.
You got this funnel for adding cooling water and this treatment cream here.
So what's so different about this one compared to the pen laser if they're both supposed to treat the same thing?
Well, pretty much everything.
Oh!
Wonka-S?
Unlike the last one, which was a diode laser, this is an old school flashlight pump laser that uses ND-YAG as a lasing medium.
In fact, it's quite similar to the first lasers ever built in that regard.
Don't let the old tech fool you, though. This is an absolutely terrifying laser.
In fact, it's so powerful that it trashed the sensors on the cameras I used to film it.
And that's without even taking a direct hit.
The peak output power here is millions of watts, which is powerful enough to ignite air at the focal point
and blow craters in a block of tungsten.
For those that watched the original video of mine, you might remember that I blew up the flash lamp while trying to make it stronger.
In my defense, I bought the laser used and the lamp was already near end of life.
Luckily, it was easy to score a replacement lamp and get the laser out.
Was haben die Amis eigentlich immer mit diesen Boxen?
Ich habe auch schon ganz viele Videos gesehen, wo die dann sagen, okay, ich habe jeden Tag so eine Box dabei
und da drin ist, keine Ahnung, zwei Klammern, ein Schweizer Taschenmesser, zwei Bonbons und so.
Die Amis stehen voll auf diese komischen Adoids-Kisten.
... zurück in die Arbeitsordnung. Natürlich ist es schwer, Wörter zu finden, um so eine Lasereinheit zu beschreiben.
Der größte Schaden mit diesem Kind ist, dass die Gagel, die mit dem Laser gesetzt wird, total unnötig für die Lasereinheit sind.
Das Fakt, dass man immer noch grünes Licht zu ihnen sieht, bedeutet, dass es hier keine Protektion gibt.
Außerdem, wie meine Kamera zeigt, braucht man nicht direkt in die Augen, um es unvergesslich zu verhindern.
Im Endeffekt, ein Set von High-OD, wrap-around Gageln, die dich eigentlich von der Lasereinheit schützen,
kostet fast so viel wie die Lasereinheit selbst.
Auf der Rückseite ist mir der Nerd wirklich beeindruckend, dass ein Q-Switch-Jagd-Lasersystem mit relativ hohem Pulsenergie
für 500 Dollar gekauft werden kann.
Ich meine, ehrlich gesagt, du wirst dich schwer beeindrucken, wenn du ein solches System auf deinem eigenen bauen würdest.
Das Laser ist klar gut, wenn man Kratereinheiten in Sachen schiebt.
Aber ist es auch gut, wenn man die Treatmenten, die man für verkauft hat?
Na ja, das ist auch ein Problem.
Jetzt sollte ich vorsichtig sein, wie ich das sage.
Aber ich denke, ein trainierter Operator könnte dieses System benutzen, um einige Typen von Tattoos zu entfernen.
Ich meine, die kurzen Pulsen und die Wavelength-Optionen sind ähnlich wie die, die du in einigen professionellen Systemen findest.
Selber wie der letzte Laser, produziert dieses System extrem kurze Pulsen, auf der Höhe von 10 Billionen Sekunden.
Dies ermöglicht den Laser, Tattoo-Pigmen zu verblutern, während die entgegenstehende Haut relativ unvergesslich ist.
Das heißt, der Grund, warum es so günstig ist, ist, weil die Sicherheitsregulationen nicht in Bezug genommen worden sind.
Das Ding ist nirgends näher zu einem idealen System. Ich meine, die Kontrollen sind sehr unvergesslich. Und manchmal schiebt der Laser, wenn die Pulsen...
Nicht bitzeln. Bitzeln ist ja, wenn du es angreifst.
Bitzeln wäre bei 230 Volt schlechter.
Okay, ich glaube aber, da kann man sich jetzt relativ sicher sein.
Ich meine, Tattoovierung machen tut schon ein bisschen weh. Und eine Tattoovierung wegmachen wird dementsprechend auch ein bisschen weh tun.
Ich glaube, das geht gar nicht ohne.
Eyebrows? Wie? Augenbrauen rausbrennen? Vor allem, es ist so ziemlich nah am Auge dran.
Ja, aber die machen das nicht mit einem AliExpress Laser.
Schreckt.
Was hat der Typ eigentlich für eine Ausrüstung daheim?
Das tut bestimmt weh?
Okay, was haben wir als nächstes? Oh ja, wie ist das Laser-Plasma-System?
Aber dieses System ist von weit her das teuerste der Bunchen. Etwas über 5 Dollar.
Das ist auch das mysteriöse. Keine Instruktionen kamen mit dem Ding, nur das Gerät und ein paar Knödel-Attachments. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich ihn benutzen soll.
Also, das sieht nicht aus wie ein Laser. Ich meine, wenn das die Ausrüstung sein soll, dann ist es sicherlich kein visible Licht, den es produziert.
Dann machen wir das Ding an. Okay, das muss aktiviert werden und das muss die Ausrüstung sein. Was ist das Ding?
Ich meine, es ist definitiv kein Laser. Es gibt keinen visible Ausrüstung, aber es brennt oder schockt oder so.
Das Ding kann definitiv brennen, aber das Ding ist nicht heiß. Also, es muss eine hohe Elektrizität produzieren, um so zu brennen.
Okay, schau dir das an. Da es diesen Neon-Bolben anbrennen kann, muss das Ding relativ hohe Voltage produzieren.
Ich meine, diese Sachen brennen nicht bis zu 100 Volt oder so.
Okay, das ist wirklich beeindruckend. Also, das ist ein Nixie-Bolb hier. Und schau dir das an, es brennt das ganze Ding an.
Ja, es brennt das ganze Ding an. Ich kann es sogar kapazitiv durch das Glas machen. Wow, das ist wirklich, wirklich cool.
Ich habe mit dem Ding ein bisschen mehr gespielt.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass es eine Art Art für Objekte produziert, die ein bisschen Kapazität zu ihnen haben.
Es ist eigentlich ein bisschen lustig, mit anodisierten Metallen zu brennen, wenn die Macht kaputt ist.
Außerdem kann ich es benutzen, um dumme Sachen auf einem Apfel zu drehen.
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Ist das ein Schwachsinn?
Also, die Sache ist, dass hohe Voltage und hohe Frequenzen in der Medizin verwendet werden, um Schmerzen zu brennen.
Sie sehen nicht genau so aus.
Die Idee selbst ist ziemlich cool.
Denn bei hohen Frequenzen kann die Polarität schneller geblendet werden als Nervzellen.
Deshalb kann es brennen, aber nicht Schock.
Natürlich spricht das nichts über die Sicherheit dieses Dinges.
Das sagt auch, dass ich einen Schock entfernen möchte, um zu sehen, wie gut es funktioniert.
Dieser Schock hier scheint mir einen Schock zu machen.
Hier geht nichts.
Warum mache ich das?
Das tut weh, oder?
Das tut weh.
Oh mein Gott.
Das riecht so schlecht.
Das war extrem unbeleidigend.
Ich bin jetzt zu unbeleidigend, um zu sehen, wie das Ding funktioniert.
Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass die Narbe besser ist.
Aber je nachdem, wie das gefällt, muss es alles, was du im Schock hast, funktionieren.
Dann wird es viel schlimmer.
Es kann auch ein Risiko sein, dass hier Tissuebrennen liegen.
Ich bin gespannt, was da drin ist.
Deshalb werde ich es entfernen.
Wow, die FDH und die FCC würden ein Schock über dieses Ding haben.
Ist das ein Slayer-Exciter-Circuit?
Ich meine, die Brennen von diesem Ding fühlen sich sehr an wie die Brennen, die mein Slayer-Exciter mir gibt.
Au!
18-6-5-0, ja.
Und jetzt?
Oh!
Hat er da gerade einen Kondensator dran gemacht oder was?
Ich konnte sie ja erkennen.
What the fuck?
Sowas kann man bei Ali...
Sowas kann man ernsthaft bei AliExpress kaufen?
Ein Krankenhaus-Laser?
eBay, eBay, ja.
Was sind denn 150 grand?
Ist das 115.000?
Ist das 11.500?
150.000?
150.000, ok, alles klar.
Also 150k, ok.
Ok, das ist teuer.
Können die nicht einfach mal gescheite Einheiten benutzen?
Oh, was passiert jetzt?
Boah!
Ist ja schlimmer als die alte Xbox.
Ach nee, das ist was, was er schon vorher gebaut hat.
Boah!
Ok, das haut gut rein.
Erst mal schön, erst mal schön auf den Arm.
Ah, yes.
Ah, das wird immer besser.
Boah!
Bonkers!
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass man sich sowas kaufen kann auf eBay.
Gut, aber warum mich?
Man kann ja auch ausrangierte Hardware auf eBay kaufen.
Sind wahrscheinlich 386er oder was da drauf ist, das Zeug ist ja immer uralt.
Und jetzt, jetzt hat das und weiter, also was genau, außer dass es cool ist zu haben.
Doktor Magic, fünf Monate, Dankeschön für das Zapp.
Ja, was macht der denn sonst so?
Laser, Laser, Laser, Laser, ok, der macht sehr viel Laserzeug, wie es aussieht.
Exquisite Laser.
Und ich hab Hunger.
Ok.
Ich muss jetzt noch ne Runde.
Ok, wir skippen mal schnell über den Minecraft-PC drüber.
Ach guck mal, er wieder.
Den hatten wir schon öfters mal am Start hier.
DDR2?
What the f, wo sind wir da gelandet?
Ok, acht Euro, was willst du, ja.
Ja, sowas hatte ich mal 2005 oder so.
Bestimmt, bestimmt, bestimmt, top LC-Power-Netzteil.
Spielst du Overwatch?
Ne, Blizzard hat es auch verkackt.
Oh, also schneller als, ne ich mach, der Witz hat so einen Bart, den muss ich jetzt nicht bringen.
Witzig ist ja, dass wir bald wieder in der nächsten oder übernächsten Grafikkarten-Generation wieder bei Nummern sind, wo wir vor zehn Jahren mal waren.
Ich weiß aber, dass ich diese Grafikkarte irgendwann mal besessen habe vor ein paar Jahren.
Ach, NX 7300, alles klar, so, NVIDIA GeForce 7300, wahrscheinlich mit 256 Megabyte Videospieche, also eigentlich nur ein purer Ausgang für ein Office-PC, ich glaube heutzutage auch noch zu schlecht.
Aber schlecht für alles.
Wir sehen, das Netzzelt ist hier irgendwie so ein bisschen komisch reingelegt, aber das ist nicht befestigt.
Ich weiß nicht warum, vielleicht ist das Ding kaputt oder auch nicht.
Die Grafikkarte, ich verwechsel ganz auf Grafikkarte und Festplatte.
Er hat die Festplatte hier drin gelassen.
Ja, sieht ja auch recht ähnlich aus, kann man ja schon mal verwechseln.
Und meinte dann auch, ja, ich muss sie dann auch eben formatieren.
Und es ist immer besser mir zu vertrauen, dass ich die Daten...
Ist das ein Pentium 4?
Ich runterlösche, weil wenn dann irgendjemand irgendwo eine Festplatte drin hat, teilweise auch in der Playstation oder in einem kaputten Laptop oder irgendwas in der Art, dann ist das immer doof, weil er da eine Festplatte zu Hause rumliegen hat.
Und Festplatten einzeln nachkaufen, dafür ist auch immer doof, weil, weiß ich nicht, für eine 120 Gigabyte Festplatte 10 Euro finde ich dann auch schon wieder zu viel.
Wenn man so mal guckt, was die gebraucht kosten, dann kann man sich schon besser eine SSD nehmen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Gerade so alte Rechner profitieren auch richtig von SSDs.
Generell alles profitiert von SSDs.
Ein PC-Express-Stromanschluss, ja, ja.
Okay, ich leg das Ding mal eben hin, schließe es an und guck mal, ob es überhaupt funktioniert.
Ja, das hab ich tatsächlich gar nicht gefragt.
Ich hab das Ding nur gesehen und das sieht ja eigentlich relativ sauber aus.
Ich geh mal davon aus.
Es ist wohl auch Standard, dass bei so alten Dinger die Slotplatten fehlen.
Das hatte ich bei meinen alten Rechnern auch oft.
Das ist funktioniert und wenn nicht...
Ich hab mal eine Zeit lang, wo ich Rechner zusammengebaut hab, war ich sogar zu faul, die Slotplatten reinzusetzen und hab's einfach so gemacht, weil ich hab mir gedacht, wer braucht Slotplatten?
Wird mal wieder ziemlich dumm.
Aber ich dachte, erst im Nachhinein, ja, okay, da könntest du mal ein Video drüber machen, weil mir gerade leider Videoideen fehlen.
Und wenn ich Ideen habe, dann muss ich die noch weiter ausschmücken, weil ich die sonst nicht gut genug finde für ein Video.
Und nun steht das Ding auf...
Ach, Verlängerungskabel, da lag's drin, ja.
Boah, man muss da so ein Stück Plastik runterdrücken.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Gehen wir direkt mal ins Plastik.
Gehen wir direkt mal ins BIOS.
Das ist aber noch aus Zeiten, wo die Innenleben vom Rechner weder RGB waren, noch irgendwie großartig verblendet oder so.
Da sah PC-Innenleben halt wie PC-Innenleben aus.
Jemand hatte sich mal beschwert, dass ich...
Kann man sein PC mit einer SSD aufrüsten ohne Windows neu aufsetzen zu müssen?
Du kannst kopieren.
Das geht wahrscheinlich, ja.
Anstelle von BIOS, nicht BIOS sagen würde, weil's ja das englische Wort dazu wäre.
Ich bin für BIOS.
BIOS.
Das hört sich so...
Ich bin sauer.
Und dies bin ich in der Tat, weil gerade nix passiert.
Also, so gar nix.
BIOS größer EFI.
Schau, was der sagt.
Ich nenn auch heute noch...
Ich nenn auch heute noch das Zeugchen BIOS.
Da. Zusammen mit Arbeitsspeicher.
Wunderschön, Philipp.
Habe gerade mal die Grafikkarte rausgenommen und gesehen, dass sie hier ein wenig...
Ist das Schimmel oder so?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Angefackelt.
Erstmal mit dem Laser vorher drauf gelasert auf die Grafikkarte.
Dann sieht die so aus.
Kann wohl passieren, wenn das Ding so da drin sitzt.
Also kein Wasser natürlich, sondern Cola oder irgendwie so was.
Ich hab jetzt mal eine GTX 650 reingepackt.
Die hab ich ja auch noch da.
Und ohne die Grafikkarte ist es zumindest angegangen gerade eben.
Ah, beep. Perfekt.
Auch mit beiden RAM-Slots drin.
Der Post-Beep.
Oh Gott, oh nein.
Weißt du, ist ja niemand so oldschool und weiß, wofür Post steht überhaupt?
Post-Champ?
Power und Selbsttest.
Ah, wir haben exquisite Big Brain, Leute.
Weil sowas war jetzt...
Was?
Und wir haben ein Pentium-Dual-Core. Oh Gott.
Oh!
Gar kein Pentium-4?
Doch, doch, doch. Das ist ein Pentium-4.
Das ist doch okay.
Das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Pentium-4-Dual-Core.
Nee, das ist...
Das ist noch nicht mal ein Pentium-4.
Was ist denn das? Ein Core-to-Duo?
E-5007.
2010, so alt ist das gar nicht.
Dual-Core-Pentium von 2010, ja, das ist...
Das ist sogar relativ neu.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht gut.
Ja.
Doch, okay.
Ja, das geht auch.
Ich hab grad mal kurz recherchiert, das sollen um die 120 Punkte
im Cinebench F15 sein.
Ich mein, es sind immerhin 3 Gigahertz, aber ich würde doch trotzdem kurz...
Wer weiß wo für BIOS steht?
Ach, das wissen nur noch die Hardcore-Leute. Also ich weiß es.
Es fängt mit BASIC an.
Und nicht mit Microsoft BASIC.
Dann mal schauen, was haben wir hier?
Wi-Fi Chat weiß das bestimmt, Basic Input Output ist korrekt, korrekt, korrekt, der Chat
ist wieder too smart, die vielen Subs haben sich gelohnt hier, die haben explodiert.
Nichts zu lesen, werden wir später noch genau rausfinden, ja ok, aber zumindest gut zu
sehen, dass das Ding läuft, die Grafikate hätte ich nämlich eh nicht weiter verwendet,
Australian Ramsey, Twitch Prime, dankeschön für den Sub, mehr IQ für den Chat wieder.
Gar nicht, das war wahrscheinlich dabei.
Ja, Crap, Crap, die gibts heute übrigens immer noch zu kaufen ne, die kriegt man heute
noch neu, äh, die kriegt man heute noch neu, warum alles in der Welt wollen die 40 Euro
dafür haben?
WTF?
Ja, Figi war dran, bin erkannt, alles klar, ok, Eats, Eats Flash 2 ist es, Eats, ja das
Ding ist ja nicht das schnellste, ok, es ist irgendwie nicht hochgefahren, ich habe dann
zwischendurch über die Onboard Grafik mal ein Bild gekriegt, dass die System, äh, jetzt
habe ich leider das Wort dafür vergessen, auf jeden Fall wurde der PC in Standby Modus
gepackt, darauf kann man, war das, waren das schon, das waren schon 64bit CPUs ne, also
da kann man, da könnten wir schon theoretisch Windows 10 drauf installieren, jaja 2010 war
definitiv viel sehr spät.
Ich habe auch noch ne, ich habe hier noch ne, äh, 7900 GTX am Start, von so Oldschool
Grafikkarten, ah, yes, Hackerman am Start, es ist eine 150G Platte, oh ja, geht doch,
ne 200, guck mal, sogar 230G Platte, ne habe ich nicht Florian, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Florian, aber interessiert mich echt das Teil, ey, gibt es noch, die erste Grafikkarte,
die ich mir jemals selbst gekauft habe, war eine Elsa Eraser 2, kriegt man die noch irgendwo?
Genau das Ding hier, genau das Ding, TNT 1, wann war das, 98 oder so, so ungefähr als
Half-Life angesagt war, Let's Build Max First Gaming PC, das war, ich glaube das war ein
Pentium 2 400, damals mit einer TNT 1, das müsste 98 gewesen sein, soll das sein, ja,
das kommt hin, das kommt hin, ja, das war so mein, das war mein erster Rechner, mein
erster Rechner hat glaube ich eine, die ist aber zu fett, die ist zu fett, meine Grafikkarte
war nicht so fett, die sah so aus, also das war, ich überlege gerade, ich glaube es hatte
ein Pentium 2 400, den habe ich übertaktet auf 450 und kam mir wie der krasseste Hackerman
aller Zeiten vor, ne, als ich den Rechner damals übertaktet habe, damals hast du die
CPUs auch nur über Frontside-Bass übertaktet, ich glaube das hatte standardmäßig 100, 100
MHz Frontside-Bass und dann hatte ich irgendwie übertaktet, kein Ahnung, 110 oder so und
dann kam ich mir richtig Hackerman vor mit 450 MHz, dann hatte ich eine TNT 1 drinne
und ich weiß gar nicht wie viel RAM, ehrlich gesagt 64 MB kann das sein, was hat man damals
so in einem Pentium 2 Rechner gehabt, 64 MB, 32, 64 MB, wir können, wir können einfach
gucken, Half Life 1 Hardware Requirements, ne, dann hatte ich 108, was, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das stimmt definitiv nicht.
WTF
Ja
Also, der kein wow, aber 64 mb RAM kommt glaub hin
Also es war ein Pentium 2, 400, dann steht übertaktet, ich glaube 64 oder 128 mb ram
oder irgendwie ne, das mainboard war so nichts sagen, das kackding, das war so mein erster
gaming pc und ich weiß noch den haben wir beim media, oh das, das, jetzt wirds eklig
leute, die story hab ich glaub ich nicht erzählt, oh jetzt wirds jetzt wirds eklig, also den
haben wir damals beim media mark gekauft den pc, für 2000 mark, waren das noch, 2000 mark
und danach hab ich mir noch ne grafikkarte gekauft, also die tnt 1, der kam ja ein bisschen
später, kam ja, kam ja ein bisschen später, genau, den rechner hatte ich schon ein bisschen
und ich hab mir dann irgendwie ein halbes jahr später oder so ne tnt 1 gekauft, so
und den rechner haben wir damals gekauft beim media mark, 2000 mark waren das noch, war
damals richtig viel, aber es war damals ziemlich, ziemlich high end, ja, es war damals ziemlich
high end, pentium 2, 400, übertaktbar auf 450, dabei war glaub ich als grafikkarte
eine rti 3d rage pro, wenn das ding noch irgendwie einer kennt, war damals auch gar nicht so
schlecht das teil und danach hab ich nen tnt 1 eingebaut und das geile war, damals konnte
man schon, das ist dann was dann später wieder schlechter geworden ist witzigerweise, damals
konnte man schon in diesem setting half life spielen 1600 mal 1200, überlegt euch mal,
wir hatten damals schon, ich jetzt übertreib ich mal, aber fast fast full hd auflösung,
ja nicht wirklich, aber was ist denn 1600 mal 1200 ist was, ok und was ist 1920 mal
1080, wie, ahja, guck mal so ein großer unterschied an pixel ist das nicht, das ist, das ist
fast full hd auflösung, ja, full hd 4 zu 3 full hd, so, also man konnte damals schon
1600 mal 1200 halbwegs flüssig spielen half life 1 mit ner tnt 1, es war damals das ähm,
damals war es das richtige format, weil die monitore auch noch 4 zu 3 waren, da hatte
ich so nen 21er, 23er, 24er schon richtig fetten ultra schweren, glaub samsung war das
bildschirm, dann eines tages abgeraucht ist und wo ich so doof war den aufzuschrauben,
gut dass ichs überlebt habe, also crts aufschrauben, selbst wenn du sie ausgeschaltet hast, war
es echt nicht ohne, ja und zumindest, als wir den rechner gekauft haben zum mediamarkt,
sind wir zum mediamarkt gefahren nach erschaffenburg, das weiß ich noch, und da fährt man ne weile
von uns aus, wir sind irgendwie so eineinhalb stunden unterwegs gewesen, und ich war so
ultra, ich hab mit nem freund zusammen aus der schule, der hat sich den gleichen rechner
gekauft, wir sind mit meinem vater zum mediamarkt gefahren, und ich war so super excited, da
war ich grad bei meiner oma, als wir losgefahren sind, die hat mich da abgeholt, und ähm,
ne ne, nicht 60hz, die monitore hatten 85, 85, teilweise sogar 100, 85 hat es zum meisten
so, ähm, so und ich war halt so super aufgeregt, endlich holst du mal einen neuen computer,
endlich holst du mal einen neuen computer, und ich hab schon gemerkt, leute, wie gesagt
jetzt wirds paints champ story, ich sag's euch jetzt schon gleich, du hast dir in die
hose gepingelt, fast, fast, so ähnlich, so ähnlich, fast, fast, und ich hab schon gemerkt
beim losfahren, dass ich eigentlich mal aufs klo musste, aber ich war so excited, dass
ich gesagt hab, alter ich spring jetzt ins auto, wir fahren los, wir sind ja gleich da,
und ähm, während wir dann auf der autobahn waren, musste ich mal ultra pissen, und das
schlimme war, wir waren im stau, keck wait, das war auch noch stau, und ich musste so
krass dringend aufs klo, mein vater hat gesagt, wir können nicht neben ran fahren, wir kommen
da im leben nicht wieder rein, dann hab ich mir den verbandskasten genommen, hab das ganze
zeugs rausgeschmissen, und habe den verbandskasten gepinkelt im auto, und das haben wir dann
ausgeleert, und dann hab ich mein rechner gekauft, ja, abenteuerliche geschichte, abenteuerliche
geschichte, und aufm parkplatz weiß ich noch, man konnte ja nicht alles in diesen verbandskasten
machen, dass so groß sind die dinger nicht, vor allem nicht im fahren, während das rum
wackelt, ja, also da hab ich nur das nötigste da reingenickt, so, aber es hat dann quasi
immer noch gedrückt, selbst im mediamarkt, und ich bin nicht, ich war so begeistert, so
scharf auf den neuen rechner, ich bin dann erst, nachdem wir den rechner hatten, und
der im kofferraum war, in die hecke, und hab gefühlt, übertrieben gesagt, ne viertel
stunde in die hecke gepinkelt, ja, und dann sind wir zurückgefahren, äh, weil der mediamarkt
verkäufer, war ja damals auch so ein dreck sack, der hat gesagt, ich kann ihnen das nur
reservieren bis um 13 uhr oder so, und wir waren dann erst um 13.45 da, weil wir stau
hatten, und wir haben uns alle gedacht, oh fuck, der rechner ist bestimmt weg, damals,
damals waren das noch zeiten, wo man schlangen, wo man in schlangen vorm aldi pc gewartet
hat und sowas, ja, und dann hat sich rausgestellt, der typ war gar nicht da an dem tag, der
uns das reserviert hat, das wär auch bis 20 uhr für uns reserviert gewesen, und da
sind wir beide dann zurückgefahren, ultra happy, wie alt war ich denn da, das müsste
so 97 oder so gewesen sein, mitte, mitte, sommer 97, irgendwie, da war ich 13 oder
so, viernachtig bin ich geboren, 13.14 oder so war ich da, und wir waren ultra happy,
dass wir beide jetzt so richtig geilen rechner hatten, erst mal heimgekommen, windows 8.90,
windows 95, glaub am anfang noch installiert, ja, mit 13 erstmal pc für 2k, ja, tja, und
die hab ich zum größten teil selbst bezahlt, ich hab da richtig lang drauf gespart, also
ne, das stimmt nicht, die hälfte hab ich ungefähr selbst bezahlt, ich hab da richtig
gespart und alles gesammelt und auch extra guten noten geschrieben, dass man was abgreifen
konnte von opa, oma und allen, durch das gespart, also die hälfte hab ich ungefähr
selbst bezahlt, ja, richtig nice, ja, so war das, das ist eigentlich mal ne storytime video,
was ich in nem youtube video erzählen könnte, oder, das, bisschen ausgeschmückt noch mit
ein paar mehr sachen, aber, so sahs aus, ja, ja, man hat sich dann auch getroffen zum spielen
zusammen, wir haben dann zusammen bei mir daheim gesetzt mit bnc-netzwerk und hatten
nen 56k modem, das kann ich mir noch dran erinnern, wir haben daheim gesetzt mit bnc-netzwerkkarten
zusammen, hatten nen 56k modem oder eventuell schon isdn einwahl, ich weiß es gar nicht
mehr, und dann hab ich zum ersten mal so nen proxy installiert auf windows, ich wusste
gar nicht, was ich da mache, und später haben wir, kennt das noch einer, winroot, winroot
pro hatten wir dann, ja, dieses kackding, das war so das erste mal, wo wir isdn internetverbindungen
freigegeben haben, genau so sah das aus, winroot pro, genau so, ja, richtig hässlich und crap
eigentlich nur, das war so quasi das internet connection sharing von damals, das hieß ja,
in windows hieß das ja später internetverbindungsfreigabe, weil microsoft die sachen geil übersetzt hat,
heute hast du nen router, der macht natt, du hast die probleme gar nicht mehr, aber damals
hatte ich das isdn an meinem rechner, und auf meinem rechner hab ich dann dieses ding
laufen lassen, da konnten wir zu zweit ins internet, und dann haben wir zusammen cs gespielt,
also damals hat man jetzt cs nicht so gespielt wie heute, damals hat man hauptsächlich geisel
retten gespielt und dings, diese ölmap, kennt noch jemand diese ölmap mit dem vip in cs,
ich red jetzt die erste, wahrscheinlich gibt es die es gar nicht mehr, oilrig war das
glaub ich, wo du mit so nem vip rumstellen musstest und den beschützen musstest und
sowas, ja das haben wir damals online gespielt, und irgendwann sind wir da auf die glorreiche
idee gekommen und haben gesagt, wir nehmen nen alten rechner und machen da nen halflife
server drauf, da hatten wir irgendwie nen pentium 266 oder 233 oder sowas, und haben
dann nen halflife server gehostet mit isdn, und es ging, und es ging, und wir haben das
richtig, wir haben uns das so abgefeiert dabei, weil wir dann halt nen lokalen ping hatten
von eins, und die leute die übers internet connected haben hatten halt nen ping von 150-250,
und wir haben die halt so krass geowned, weil wir lokalen einser ping hatten, das war schon
nice, wir haben es aber damals nicht gecheckt, wir hätten damals den server limitieren mussten
auf 6 spieler oder sowas, halt irgendwas was mit isdn kanalbündelung auch läuft, wir
haben dann den server halt großgemacht, was dann halt gelackt hat, as fuck und so, aber
das war schon geil, das war schon geil, muss ich echt sagen, ja so, ja, das war schon,
das war schon nice, falls das überhaupt noch jemand kennt hier, bmc-netzwerk-karte, so
sah der, what is, so sah die dinger aus, genau, realtech-dinger, mit scheiß windows-treiber,
so sah die dinger aus, die späteren hatten hybrids, so hast du es dann gemacht, du hast
dann quasi an deine netzwerk-karte, damn dennis, dankeschön für den prime, du hast an deine
netzwerk-karte angeschlossen, so ein t-stück, da hast du das kabel hingemacht, das ist genau
so ein kabel und am ende musstest du noch einen terminator drauf machen, sonst ging
das netzwerk nicht, 50ohm terminator, genau, am ende musstest du so einen terminator drauf
machen, also da war noch nichts mit aj45-stecker und wir fanden damals aj45-stecker und kabel
fanden wir total inferior, schlecht, fanden wir schlechter als bmc, weil damals hat man
sich ja noch offline getroffen zum spielen und wir waren dann oftmals bei einem freund
aus der schule und da lief es halt so, der hatte sein zimmer unterm dach, im ersten stock
hat seine schwester gewohnt und wenn die halt alle nicht da waren, haben wir uns da breit
gemacht mit 5 leuten und du musstest halt einmal ein kabel legen, quasi vom erdgeschoss,
teilweise sogar keller, wenn es viele leute waren, bis unters dach und es ging halt mit
so einem bmc-kabel richtig geil, weil so ein bmc-kabel hast du einfach von einem rechter
zum nächsten rechter, zum nächsten rechter und links und rechts war die schwester hübsch,
nee, weiß nur noch, dass sie rothaarig war, ich hab keine ahnung mehr genau wie die ausgeschaut
hat und dann hast du oben einen terminator dran gemacht im dach und im keller und da
ging das, also sprich man hat nur ein langes kabel gebraucht durchs ganze haus und wir
haben halt gesagt, alter warum sollten wir jetzt mit nem switch und aj45-kabeln anfangen
da müssen wir ja auf einmal irgendwie 7 kabel komplett durchs haus ziehen, so nen schwachsinn,
warum sollten wir das machen, wenn wir doch ein kabel nehmen können, also für uns war
damals bmc und diese terminator-geschichte die bessere variante für netzwerk als die
switch aj45-geschichte, esser nett war es beides, ja, ja so war das damals, wo man
jetzt erzählt was, ja ich weiß, aber das war schon nice ehrlich gesagt, war schon cool,
ja und dann haben wir dann da gesessen und ihr wisst, ihr wisst wahrscheinlich nicht,
aber wisst ihr, mal frage an den chat, wisst ihr was das erste war, was man auf so nem offline
treffen gemacht hat mit leuten, also man hat sich offline getroffen, jeder hat seinen rechner
monitor mitgebracht und hat die ganzen sachen vernetzt, was war das erste was man gemacht hat,
pizza bestellt, ja ok mal ne, aber sowas, file share, ja das auch, das auch, file share, ja das
stimmt, file share haben wir auch da, nein man hat windows neu installiert, man hat windows neu
installiert, weil irgendwas im netzwerk nicht funktioniert hat und das einzige womit man sich
zu helfen wusste war windows neu installieren, also im prinzip bestand 50 prozent dieser treffen
aus windows neu installieren und dann über nen 100 mbit oder 10 mbit, nicht 100, 10 mbit netzwerk,
10 mbit netzwerk, sich half life und irgendwelche serial keys zu ziehen, dann musste noch ipx
anhaken für half life sowas, ladet euch mal half life mit 10 mbit netzwerk runter, das sitzt
in der ganze weile, ach ja war schon nice, war schon nice, also ehrlich gesagt war es nicht nice,
aber so die erinnerung drin ist, ok schauen wir mal weiter, also wirklich uralt, aber immerhin
in office key, ich benutze office nicht so oft und wenn, dann verwende ich open office oder
libre office oder sowas, gar kein office ist besser, ich hasse office-produkte, alles crap,
egal ob microsoft office, libre office, open office, king dingsbums office, office-produkte
sind müll, ich vermeide office-produkte wo es nur geht, no office, naja irgendwas muss man nutzen,
wie wärs einfach mit texteditor und das dann nach ordentlich rendern, ok tabellen, wie gesagt
excel ist finde ich die einzige daseinsberechtigung von office, wenn man das wirklich braucht, was
nimmst du dann anstatt von office in texteditor, meistens mit markdown und dann wird das als ordentliches
html formatiert, eventuell sogar direkt als pdf, da kann man es auch verschicken und jeder kann es lesen
dann überholt er sich ja meistens selbst und dann muss ich mal schauen was ich hier für eine
grafikkarte habe, powerpoint braucht man auch nicht, ich mach auch meine präsentation immer in markdown,
ja könnten wir auch machen, nicht für 8 euro, könnten wir wirklich mal machen gell, ja dann
machen wir, aber das reicht für 8 euro nicht mehr, mal schauen, mal schauen, wenig später ist
winnows dann auch installiert ohne probleme soweit und ich habe auch mal ein cdbench test
gestartet wir haben 144 punkte rausgekriegt, ohne treiber oder besser gesagt ohne einmal
neu zu starten, ich habe da nämlich einfach ein laden reingesteckt, winnows hat sich die treiber
für die onboard grafik und so selber rausgesucht, ja den plan eine ssd zu verbauen habe ich verworfen
weil das hier das ding wahrscheinlich im normalen gebrauch ein wenig, also die ssd kostet mehr als
der ganze rechner, ne das stimmt das glaube ich nicht dass das stimmt ssd bringen immer was,
das lohnt sich glaube ich einfach wirklich nicht, ssd sind immer poggers, finde ich,
die ich noch in meiner sammlung drin habe das ist ne ati hd 5450, hatte ich auch mal ganz kurz ich
hatte mal ganz kurz eine ati was hd 5600 irgendwas das war so zu zeiten wo man far cry 1 gespielt
hat und da war ich richtig da hatte ich vorher eine geforce 3 und da war ich richtig begeistert dass
es auf einmal tiefenunschärfe effekte und sowas gab, richtig poggers, richtig begeistert auf einmal
von dem game, 4000 545 50 keine keine ahnung also hat hat irgendwie damit kann man ein paar netflix
filme gucken, ich meine wenn man ehrlich ist crisis 1 ist der far cry 1 nachfolger, far cry 2 war
nicht mehr crytek im prinzip so die originale crytek geschichte ist far cry 1 und dann crisis 1
na und mehr sollte hiermit auch eigentlich nicht so gemacht werden weil das einfach auch leider zu
halten, ja jetzt zeig mal ob da minecraft gut drauf läuft, ob man mit diesem mainboard überhaupt quadcore cpus
verwenden kann gibt ja so einige modelle, also wenn er jetzt acht also das ist aber nicht mal acht
euro und da würde ich noch mal sagen probieren wir zu und das mainboard ist so dieses dieses gute alte
computer innenleben braun entweder waren die dinger blau grün oder braun in der regel war es so ganz
ganz früher waren die dinger grün also so zu 386 oder 486 dann waren die dinger grün teilweise
teilweise rot ja aber damals waren die dinger meistens grün danach kam also eine phase wo die
blau und braun waren und heute sehen die dinger ja besser aus als manche manche küchengeräte quasi
so nach dem auto also mittlerweile ist das innenleben von einem pc gestylt bis zum geht nicht mehr
das könnte so gerade eben funktionieren werden wir dann aber gleich sehen und wenn man jetzt sagt
ok packen wir dann kurz zwei quad rein nehmen die gtx 650 oder vielleicht eine gtx 700 die grafikkarte
sieht auch die grafikkarte sieht ernsthaft so aus als hat jemand in der mitte durchgebrochen oder
die grafikkarte sieht aus als hätte die jemand hier abgebrochen sieht original so aus hat die
einfach jemand genommen einmal in der mitte durchgebrochen 650 oder vielleicht eine gtx 750 ti packen
die hier mit zusammen dann kann das vielleicht auch sinnvoll sein ich glaube ich werde wieder
krank das ist echt toll weil ich war jetzt zwei wochen gesund und dann wieder erkältet ich mache
mal so nun habe ich hier auch mal eine grafikkarte eingebaut nämlich die hd 5450 habe ich ja schon
gesagt zusätzlich dann hier auch mal ein bisschen was sauber gemacht ich sehe aber gerade auf der
festplatte ist immer noch was ok ich glaube ich muss die festplatte noch mal rausnehmen das sieht
echt nicht schön aus erstmal ordentlich abrubbeln alles vor allem mit der grafikkarte weil ich sie
nämlich reingepackt habe dann entweder gar kein bild kam und später kam jetzt ist der rechner auch
viel schneller wenn die festplatte sauber ist kann ich verstehen ist ein bisschen wie rgb sind aber
diesem bios bild hängen geblieben das war auch nicht so schön auch noch neustart nicht und nun
ja dann habe ich meinen kleinen trick 17 wieder angewandt grafikkarte raus tritt 17 bestes ganz
bisschen bremsenreiniger einmal durch den pc express lot durch im endeffekt mit dem lüster
einmal kurz dadurch mir ist gerade aufgefallen das könnte auch perfekt so ein mini laubbläser
sein habe ich nämlich heute gesehen weil ist ja wieder herbst und dann ein so ein typ an der straße
ist ok das ist big brain taktik bremsenreiniger in pizzi express lot mit der zahnbürste und dann
rauspusten auf die idee wäre ich nicht gekommen aber ja wahnsinnig geworden bei dem gut er hat
ja ich habe ein video von ihm letztens gesehen er hat ja mal kfz mechatroniker gelernt und war
übelst unglücklich in seiner ausbildung übrigens ein cooles video kann ich echt jedem empfehlen
der vielleicht der gleiche situation also das war wirklich war immer interessant ihm dazu zu
hören bei und das hat er abgebrochen lernt jetzt fachinformatiker letztens video gesehen von ihm
zu laub und ja kann ich nur empfehlen so zum mal eben schnell sauber machen weil dann kann es
hier eben schnell durch aber er ist wohl nicht zu wie bei uns weil ich habe noch nicht gesehen ich
bin auch einmal beim netzteil gewesen da kam auch ein bisschen was raushab das netzteil unten
befestigt passt alles deswegen kann ich mir nicht erklären warum das nicht befestigt war und ich
sehe ich habe einfach weil es keiner befestigt hat oder habe ich das extra rausgenommen weil
wenn man so ein kabel raus reißt dann ist der sata slot eigentlich kaputt weil hier
solche nasen dran sind na das ist gar nicht gut so installation erfolgreich wenn es dazu
existiert dann zeige ich mir mal das protokoll ja ok jetzt auch nicht ganz verstehen was da
alles drin war ich installiere jetzt gerade per knee night mehrere programme die man so
gebrauchen kann ist ganz schnell gemacht weil man holt sich dann diesen installer und der
installiert dann alles erstmal ich installiere noch per scoop open source programme auswählen
die man auf jeden fall braucht also eigentlich fast alles bis auf media monkey habe ich noch
nie verwendet everything key pass 2 das wort man ja sowas könnte ich mal was ist praktisch
das wird dann die ja ja key pass beste so an sich geht sehr viel schneller spart und da noch
ein key pass plugin was otp kann da braucht man kein handy immer die ganze zeit dann sollten wir
hier auch gleich in der lage sein kann ich ja schon mal gucken hier minecraft dass ich das
installiert bekomme und minecraft läuft jetzt nun auch es läuft ich habe abdefined installiert und
wir haben jetzt 50 bis 60 prozent cpu auslastung und fps gescheitern an die karte aber wenn wir
jetzt hier so durch die gegend laufen 26 20 20 sogar nur wenn wir da in den baum rein gucken
also ich habe jetzt noch nicht allzu viel eingestellt habe jetzt aber mal ein paar sachen
hier ausgestellt 36 fp ist direkt flüssig da kriegt man das wirklich auch sehr sehr schlechte
hardware zum messen ist das java edition oder ist das die cc plus plus edition man könnte die
bäume glaube ich noch umstellen vielleicht noch ein 8x8 textur ein pack benutzen aber
läuft gut ja kann man sich nicht beschweren zwischen drin und das ist auch mal gut wenn
ich hier sachen abbauen kommen die blocks da für eine millisekunde wieder nee das läuft ja alles
klar perfekt so und das ganze hätte jetzt ich habe ja gesagt zehn euro für so eine karte
ungefähr für 18 euro kann man da so erstmal 18 euro mein pc gut wenn man wenn man sonst keine
andere wahl hat auch sehr viel bessere grafikkarten ich habe auch mal hier mit worden ist ja gut kann
man auch verwenden aber ich habe seit jahren key pass und ich lasse es auch so 650 für zehn euro
gekauft allerdings nicht in der ti variante ich glaube das hier dürfte sogar die ti sein oder
nee ist er nicht aber die können wir auf jeden fall reinpacken mit diesem netzteil das mit dem
block respawn hatte ich jetzt auch gedacht eher was wenn zum server leckt oder so ein bisschen mehr
rauszuholen aber wie gesagt da wird es dann viel mehr sinn machen sich ein quadro dafür zu
besorgen ich habe immer noch nicht nachgeschaut ob dieses mainboard überhaupt kurz kurz cpus
unterstützt aber sollte es oder aber dann sind wir schon in preisregion da kannst du den irgendwo
in gebrauchten rechner wahrscheinlich kaufen der deutlich besser ist kurz vor extrem kurz vor
quatt funktioniert alles oder zumindest eine ganze menge davon weil manche leute immer noch
nicht wissen man gibt einfach die modellnummer die komplette modellnummer seines mainboards
ein kommt da direkt auf die hersteller webseite geht zu support oder unterstützung assumes mainboard
und hier gibt es in irgendwas wie cpu support sprich es ist eine ganze liste wo die ganzen
dinger drin stehen und hier gibt es dann auch noch eine sektion seit bios version das heißt bei dieser
cpu müsste man sein bios jetzt noch updaten oder bei der hier zähler und duakor habe ich noch nie
gehört dass es so einen gibt aber man muss sagen dass man das auf der konsole mit dem controller
auch nicht so krass merkt wie wenn du eine schnelle treibung mit der maus machst in die trigi fps
habe ich fast nichts bezahlt zumal auf der konsole auch alle spiele um das zu verschleiern noch
motion blur an haben ja gut kann man mal machen der also wenn du wenn man wirklich so knapp bei
kasse ist es wahrscheinlich gar keine schlechte idee ok leute wir müssen jetzt noch eine runde
pleck aufs gucken ich habe übelst hunger da ist schon 14 uhr guck mal ich bin drei stunden 40
und wir gucken jetzt noch eine runde pleck aufs schreckt warum sind die gegner wieder so planlos
ja was ist gehen wir zurück zu einem black ops 1 video es sieht so aus als ob sie den
player count oder ein bisschen mehr realistisch gesehen haben am unteren konter 20.000 haben ich
nicht geguckt so ich denke das ist noch bs das nummer ist wahrscheinlich rund 1000 oder
dass ich schwachsinn was da unten steht ich habe ich habe es ja letztens mal wieder probiert auf
der xbox zu spielen kannst du es voll vergessen also du wartest ewig auf der lobby teilweise
alles die spektra nee das war eine extra die die submaschinen ganz in black ops war so ein
bisschen nicht sagen dafür ist das ding op gewesen vor allem akimbo das war glaube ich
richtig sack ich 13 tage upload streak ja das kenne ich nicht
das ist meine richtige schrott klasse
ok welken ruckets waren auch richtig am wohl so beruhigend halten sie sich jetzt wirklich an
wissen was ich finde leute die das die so eine claimer nur aus call of duty kennen die denken die
dinger sind wirklich laser gesteuert in wirklichkeit ist es einfach ein kabel und
ein knopf wo ich drauf drücke zum auslösen das hat mit laser überhaupt nichts zu tun
oder draht ja es wird auf jeden fall per schalter ausgelöst
alle wie schnell der kram nach lädt er hat bestimmt bestimmt
das ding ist ja mal richtiger sack warum legt er sich mitten auf die straße was mit dem gegner
wieder los links ist noch einer man kann echt man konnte die waffen unabhängig voneinander
nachladen wusste ich gar nicht dass das geht schreckt eigentlich konnte man nur zusammen
nachladen die welt welken ruckets waren so schlecht man musste die sich ja auch noch
per kiste holen hätte man die einfach nur in der hand gehabt oder bring ich jetzt durch
dann eben musste die sich in der kiste holen bei der way kein skill best matchmaking das
war richtig schlecht das ding das sind genau man musste sich für dafür noch die kiste
holen das mit den kisten ist richtig doof gewesen der hat echt oder er will an die kiste
der will an die kiste oder auch nicht oder hat er Glück gehabt dass da einer in der
ecke stande napalm strike war das beste für low kill streaks noch einer da unten wie
ich glaube man konnte doch sogar messern in last stand da bist du richtig geradet wenn
im last stand gemessert wurde uav napalm strike und eventuell noch das acxt oder also eigentlich
uav counter uav napalm strike wenn du last week spielen wolltest weggelegt
ich auch ich auch also ich habe meistens lasst mal überlegen uav also uav blackbird hunde
war beste was übrigens wieder mal ein beweis dafür ist gegen schlechte gegner macht jedes
spiel multiplayer spiel bock deswegen es sagt skill best matchmaking ein einfach nur du
willst du willst auch mal die chance haben auf eine richtig geile lobby wurde wurde
durch bashen kannst das zeug hält ist ja nicht jedes mal so stimm man ist gestorben
wenn einem die kiste auf den kopf gefallen ist oder
mörser strike das habe ich damals mit fabian immer so gesagt die leute dann max das heißt
mörser schlag seit ach nee mittlerweile muss ich sagen schon ein bisschen cringe was wir
damals gesagt haben ja sowohl kotra als auch mörser strike war jetzt vielleicht nicht
unbedingt die nicht so die erwachsenste ausdrücke aber who cares was war das mlc legit alter
die waffen sind richtig kacke dann hab ich überhaupt nichts gemacht
28 11 mein gott die gegner waren scheiße und seine team auch richtig
scheiße so no hand leute
damals war super humor ja was ist für eine waffe
so eine sniper so eine richtig lahme sniper was war das noch mal für eine waffe
ja kann sein da bist du echt mit der pistole besser als mit dieser kacke
stimmte ich habe schon ganz vergessen dass man damals sogar teammates wiederbeleben konnte
das hat man nie gemacht damals hat man in tdm gesagt teammates nehmen
einem die killzweck die waffe ist ja mal richtig schlecht
die gegner sind so krass ppeger ist der wahnsinn
die check absolut gar nichts aber mit ohne scheiß mit skillwest matchmaking sind die
zeiten vorbei
ja der war gar nichts gecheckt der war echt lost wie man heutzutage so schön
zu sagen richtig lost digga natürlich da lag da lag doch
irgendwas in der ecke
das ist sagt immer alles über die waffe aus wenn es besser ist zu einer pistole zu
switchen als mit dieser komischen schneiber die gegner sind ja so hardcore schlecht das
wie ist der nicht gestorbener typ
alter diese waffe die so scheiße
ich habe die mp5 auf schreck ihn weg
im 2 chance warum kein ghost also wenn schon dann richtig camping wenn schon dann richtig
Leid easy win easy win easy win. Jawoll
easy win
So eine schrottklasse
Und auch messen verbindung hat der hat der haust der haust hat es geschafft
Alter der typ der die lobby haust hat es geschafft 3 zu 19
Hatte mit seiner arschbacke gespielt oder was also
Hat er drauf gesessen und einfach nur auf dem controller hin und her gewackelt mit dem bobbis wie wie schaffst du das als haust den black ops 1 3 zu 19 zu spielen
420 ja aber selbst dann
Selbst wenn er volle dröhnung drin hat dann ist spielte muss er besser spielen
27 und 10 und 3 19 als haustalter
Guys, wir sind wie 1 oder 2 mehr bürge hier
Irgendwer muss doch negativ sein ja die anderen aber bloß nicht der lobby
Was das für eine waffe
Thermal visier mit was
Ist das der ak 74 mit mit mit
Zeit oder was ist das nicht erkennt das überhaupt was das sein soll
Das ist die ak 74 oder oder pd. Nein da ist der pd. Okay
Nacken, die challenge
Der gun kicks to much goals definitely get a kill of this camera spike here
Alter was das für krepp
Das ist auch spielbar
Without the frickin thermal wasn't bad. The gun was like low-key kind of good. I don't know gotta get this kill
Wir haben einen, wir haben zwei, beide haben auch Kopfschüsse, los geht's.
Okay, hier gehen wir mit der Kamera, Spike, wir lassen das hier, um meine Sechs zu beobachten.
Mal sehen, ob jemand hier ist.
Zwei und drei jetzt, komm schon, komm schon Bro, lass uns aufsteigen.
Das ist doch unmöglich, sowas zu spielen.
Ja, schau, Bam, jawoll, schön mit dem Kanat einfach oben rein, Noobtum.
Wie, Flag Check it.
Alter, jawoll.
Ich glaub, der ist fast besser mit diesem Visier, dass er aus der Hüfte spreist.
Die Mannschaft hat den Blackward, 11 und 1, das sollte uns helfen.
Chuck Astano hier.
Wir werden ihn drücken.
Wenn wir schnell hier herkommen, werden wir ein paar Töne bekommen.
Ja, er hat ihn.
Drücken, versuchen, unsere Töne zu holen, während wir den Blackward in der Luft haben.
Die Map ist viel zu groß. Oh, da hat das Thermal mal wirklich was gebracht.
Die Map ist viel zu groß, also ich hab Array gehasst.
Array war so eine Map, da bist du im Prinzip nur rumgerannt, dann wurdest du von einem aus der Ecke weggecampt.
Die Kommandakrieger Wauzis.
Pains Chap.
Cringe.
Jetzt werden sie weg, jetzt werden sie aber destroyed hier.
Jetzt werden sie weggesprayt.
Ernsthaft mit dieser? Okay, okay, aber die dominieren halt auch heftig.
Das ist immer so, es ist immer so, kill, streak, tot.
Echter Krieger ist am streamen? Moment.
Was streamt der heutzutage so?
Na ja.
Was streamt der denn heutzutage so?
Alter, erschreck mich nicht so.
Alter, was ist mit der Nase los?
Ja, aber das ist ein richtiger Schrott-Visier.
Oh man, es gab in Black Ops 1 auch schon viel Crap, muss man sagen.
Das Ding mit der Walvisier ist halt schon echt richtig eklig schlecht.
Wir haben ja heute fast alle Videos eingeschaut. Jetzt ist die Frage, sind wir wach?
Also ich bin wach, weil ich hab Hunger. Ich geh jetzt was essen, Leute.
Ich hab übelst Kohldampf.
Nee, kann ich nicht. Da müsste ich mich ja drum kümmern.
Vier Stunden streamen. Ja ja, richtig lang für Sonntag.
10 angefangen, jetzt 14 Uhr.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich nachher nochmal ankomme. Ich müsste eigentlich wieder was aufnehmen.
Ich bin gerade am überlegen, ob ich heute nicht Dings aufnehme,
Stellenanzeigen, Review Nummer 2, das dann morgen zusammen schnippel.
Weil das erste kam mir richtig gut an, wie viele Views hatten das jetzt?
Komm mal, 107k, nicht verkehrt, oder?
Ist da Frazier am streamen? Dann haus mir den Frazier.
Tanzverbot ist am Start. Jawoll, was macht Tanzverbot so auf Twitch? Alles klar.
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis denn, macht's gut, CU.
Ich bin weg.